monsieur le président
la séance est ouverte
le contredit analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribuée nous n'avons pas
reçu d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance
je n'en vois pas le procès-verbal est
adopté sous les réserves d'usage l'ordre
du jour rappelle la suite la discussion
du projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale pour
2023 dans un parvenu à l'amendement 2112
rectifié qui tente à insérer l'article
additionnel après l'article 2
rappel le règlement madame rossignol
je me rappelle au règlement ce fond de
sur les articles 8 du préambule de 46 et
version il concerne donc chacun leur a
compris l'exercice du droit de grève en
France de
monsieur le ministre vous appliquez la
règle du 30e indivisible c'est-à-dire
que en ce qui concerne les
fonctionnaires d'État pour deux heures
de grève il l'aurait retiré une journée
de salaire cette règle est une règle
spécifiquement appliquée au
fonctionnaire de la fonction publique
d'État puisqu'elle n'est pas appliquée
dans ces termes-là ni aux fonctionnaires
de la fonction publique hospitalière ni
au sud ni à ceux de la fonction publique
territoriale or il se trouve que le
Conseil de l'Europe a été chargé
d'examiner la compatibilité le respect
par cette règle du droit de grève qui
est garantie par l'achat social
européenne et il a rendu sa décision il
y a quelques jours et cette décision est
très claire la règle du 30e indivisible
viol l'article 6 paragraphe 4 de la
Charte sociale européenne donc monsieur
le ministre comptez-vous mettre fin à
cette règle discriminatoire
discriminatoire entre les différents
fonctionnaires d'une part et
discriminatoires à l'encontre des
salariés de la fonction publique qui use
de l'endroit de grève je vous pose cette
question aujourd'hui parce qu'elle est
régulièrement importante la veille d'un
mouvement social qui à la fois va être
très fort contre votre réforme et qui en
même temps se situe dans un contexte
particulier qui est celui d'une
inflation importante et de pression
forte sur le pouvoir d'achat donc
monsieur le ministre je comprends bien
l'intérêt vicieux qu'il pourrait y avoir
à compter sur les difficultés
financières des fonctionnaires pour
espérer qu'il renonce à exercer leur
droit de grève demain mais je n'imagine
pas que le gouvernement puisse se livrer
à un calcul aussi sordide donc il serait
bon que aujourd'hui vous annoncer au
fonctionnaires que ceux qui feront grève
quelques heures demain ne se verront pas
retirer la totalité de leur journée de
travail mais simplement leurs heures de
grève
et donner de ce rappel au règlement nous
allons examiner un amendement essai de
sous un amendement qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion
commune
un amendement
212 rectifiés
monsieur le rapporteur
bien merci monsieur le Président on
attaque dans le vif du sujet en ce qui
concerne notre stratégie d'emploi des
seniors là
cet amendement porte sur les seniors au
chômage 2 milliard 4 consacrés par
lunédique pour les chômeurs de plus de
60 ans ça doit quelque part nous
interpeller donc ce qui veut dire que
les outils actuels d'emploi des seniors
ne sont pas suffisants c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons sur proposition
de longues de partenaires sociaux
proposés ce CDI senior le CDI Seigneur
c'est quoi c'est un CDI différent
réservé un contrat entre le salarié et
son employeur pour que on définisse les
conditions de travail le les durées de
travail pour aller jusqu'au taux plein
de départ en retraite du salarié le taux
plein voulant dire être acquis à la fois
par les nombres de trimestres ou
éventuellement avec l'âge d'annulation
de la décote c'est tout à fait différent
de ce qui existe actuellement puisque
les CDI classique peuvent toujours être
utilisés mais sont pas suffisants
puisque on constate que il y a
effectivement un taux de chômage aux
alentours de la soixantaine qui est
particulièrement important c'est pour ça
qu'on veut se doter d'outils nouveaux
pour inciter pour inciter l'employeur
nous proposons une exonération de
cotisation familiales de façon à ce
qu'il y ait une incitation à aller
plutôt sur ce CDI très spécifique
négocié avec le salarié par rapport à
ces traditionnel et pour le salarié ça
me paraît intéressant puisque on adapte
les conditions de travail en fonction
effectivement de son âge ou des
phénomènes d'usure c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce CDI peut être dès à présent
me semble-t-il inscrit dans la loi et je
ne vous demande de le soutenir de façon
à ce qu'ensuite et c'est notre
préoccupation il soit discuté avec les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre des
négociations pour qu'il puisse être
adopté prise en main par les partenaires
sociaux je vous remercie
nous avons demandé que vous présentez
oui merci monsieur
on fait
nous aurions fait nous comprenons bien
l'objectif de de cette proposition de
notre de notre rapporteur
mais il y a un certain nombre de choses
sur lesquelles nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur le contenu de ce contrat je
pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre avec monsieur le rapporteur qui
nous apportera
ses réponses en attendant nous avons
souhaité poser un
amendement qui propose juste certes de
remplacer les mots dernière fin de
carrière par dernière embauche mais ça
peut paraître anodin mais ça ne l'est
pas c'est parce qu'en fait dans ce qui
est proposé ce qui nous dérange par
exemple c'est la possibilité à un
employeur de mettre fin au contrat de
travail dès que si j'ai bien compris le
salarié atteindrait la possibilité le
niveau auquel il devrait il pourrait
valider sa retraite et ça ça nous ça ça
nous paraît sous couvert d'une
proposition je le sais
qui est sincère ça nous paraît pouvoir
être comment dire un outil
supplémentaire pour des employeurs de
recruter des gens qu'on garde finalement
le moins longtemps possible mais on aura
l'occasion d'en discuter merci monsieur
le Président
Monsieur Dufour le présent
le Président mes chers collègues il est
proposé un certain amendement de
pour les mesures de signative à l'emploi
de remettre large 55 ans au lieu de 60
tels que prévu par le texte
monsieur Hainaut présente
2343 oui merci monsieur le Président si
vous le voulez bien je vais évoquer les
deux dans la même argumentation parce
qu'ils sont très très proches et il se
suivent monsieur les ministres
je vais pas reprendre l'argumentation du
rapporteur je pense que nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire que l'emploi des
seniors est un défi pour notre société
c'est aussi une question à résoudre si
on veut équilibrer notre système de
répartition et bien évidemment que ce
soit sur le plan économique financier et
surtout morale ça ne peut pas être la
variable d'ajustement des des
entreprises notre interrogation elle est
sur la bardage puisque même dans votre
argumentation hier monsieur le
rapporteur vous évoqué les vous évoquez
les 55 64 ans ou le 57
64 ans est-ce que la barre pertinente et
60 ans nous voulons lancer le débat sur
l'idée que ça pourrait être 57 ans et
qui pourrait y avoir une disposition
progressive
25% d'exonération puis 5 ans puis 75 et
puis 100 % voilà nous vous souhaitons se
débat sur l'âge pertinent pour ce CDI
senior mais bien évidemment nous
partageons l'idée nous pensons qu'elle
est tout à fait pertinente toujours
merci merci le sous-amendement
4742 madame Lubin
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
donc nous sommes opposés c'est ça
revient à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure à ce contrat dernier embauche
parce que il il peut donner lieu à la
mise à la retraite d'office avant 70
oui c'est ça ce qu'il peut donner lieu à
la mise à la retraite d'office avant 70
ans je sais pas qui ça fait rire mais
bon voilà
comme pour le reste des des salariés
non madame Lubin
4743 pour le considère comme défendu par
la même état d'esprit
oui
en est-il de même pour le 4744
merci monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement extrêmement important qui
pense qui porte sur la question des
exonérations de cotisation sociale c'est
une discussion qu'on a souvent eu dans
cette émission qu'on a régulièrement à
l'occasion du PLFSS oui on l'a à
l'occasion du pfss d'ailleurs j'avais
déposé un amendement qui prévoyait de
supprimer une exonération de cotisation
sociale sur les cotisations
d'allocations familiales justement pour
les salariés
rémunéré plus de 1,6 fois le SMIC pardon
c'est pas exactement 1,6 et dont le
Conseil d'analyses économique avait
pointé que cet exonération était sans
effet sur l'emploi donc inutile sauf à
vouloir faire des exonérations pour
faire des exonérations on avait eu un
débat intéressant dans l'hémicycle un
vote je vous rappelle qu'il avait vu
faire un acide-boue comme quoi comme
quoi la réflexion et j'en suis heureux
s'étend au-delà de nos bancs sur cette
question des exonérations de cotisation
et là il est proposé dans ce contrat ce
nouveau contrat senior de procéder à une
exonération certes que des cotisations
familles mais tout de même d'une partie
exonération ça fait quoi aussi à ce qui
avait été décidé au Père FSS je me
rappelle sur les médecins qu'on allait
inciter à continuer leur activité mais
on les exonération les exonérantes
cotisations sociales alors ces
exonérations n'ont pas de sens le
travail produit de la cotisation il faut
maintenir ses cotisations qui financent
notre système de protection sociale donc
sauf avoir une idéologie de
l'exonération quoi qu'il en coûte et
bien si on défend un système juste de
répartition fondée sur la cotisation il
faut maintenir pour tous ceux qui sont
éligibles à ce contrat l'ensemble des
cotisations sociales c'est l'objet de
cet amendement je vous remercie monsieur
le Président est-ce que je considère que
l'ensemble est sous amendements
présentés par le groupe socialiste ont
été défendus madame Lubin
non le 44
bon madame Rossignol je chanterai
l'explication de votre vous êtes
enregistré depuis un moment
excusez-moi monsieur le président
[Musique]
offensif sur les allocations familiales
sur la politique nataliste n'est pas
exactement mon sujet et sur les moyens
que nous devons y consacrer et pour cela
vous êtes prêt malgré cela vous êtes
prêt à supprimer pour le contrat dernier
embauche une part des cotisations
allocations familiales qui pèse
aujourd'hui sur les employeurs donc je
vous appelle simplement par cette
amendement avec mes collègues à être
cohérent entre d'une part votre vision
de la politique familiale et d'autre
part votre vision des moyens de croître
l'emploi des seniors merci alors nous
allons demander l'avis de la commission
sur l'ensemble des sous amendements
sur le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
deux minutes par sous amendement je suis
pas obligé de les utiliser rassurez-vous
monsieur le Président mais ça nécessite
quand même des précisions un nous avons
pas parlé du coup pas d'histoire
d'argent monsieur le ministre entre nous
cependant il y a des répercussions
effectivement et vous avez annoncé à ce
titre là un coup de 800 millions d'euros
qu'aurait ce contrat là parce que vous
pensez qu'il y aura un effet d'aubaine
et que les employeurs vont pas discerner
la différence entre le CDI classique et
le CDI senior qui est différent alors
effectivement on arrive et je confirme
je confirme c'est c'est 800 millions
d'euros mais je pense que le CDI senior
c'est autre chose et s'il y a des
exonérations on peut les estimer plus on
les estime ces exonérations de façon
importante plus plus le bénéfice est
important pour l'ensemble de la société
car si on fait des exonérations à un
coup de prohibitif ça veut dire que
derrière les cotisations familiales
c'est entre 30 et 5 entre 3 et 5% sur
40% de cotisations salariale et
patronales donc si vous perdez pour le
budget de l'État ou de la sécurité
sociale 3 à 5 % et que vous gagnez 40 -
3 5 35 à 37 %, c'est tout bénef et
pendant que votre Seigneur est employé
dans un cadre particulier de ce CDI
senior avec un accompagnement et bien il
n'est pas au chômage et le chômage on
sait que ça coûte cher donc l'intérêt
pour la société pour les contes de
l'État pour les contes de la sécurité
sociale c'est que ce dispositif enfin
marche parce qu'on en a déjà essayé
beaucoup et ça n'a pas toujours marché
il n'empêche que si nous avons une
vision différente contre l'emploi des
seniors il faut se douter d'outils
nouveaux donc je lance effectivement
cette piste là et c'est les partenaires
sociaux qui vont définir par branche
quels sont les branches intéressées si
des branches ne sont pas il n'y a pas de
voilà si les branches sont intéressées
et bien elle définissent qu'elle doit
être les conditions de négociation entre
le salariale employeur quant à cet
accompagnement jusqu'à l'âge légal et
c'est comme les contrats chantiers quand
vous construisez un collège et il y a
des présidents de départements qui sont
là quand vous le construisez un collège
ça dure entre 3 5 7 ans parfois plus et
en conséquence quand vous embauchez des
personnes vous prenez un CDI chantier de
la durée du chantier là c'est la durée
de la fin de carrière merci monsieur le
Président mais je tenais à présenter ces
précisions maintenant je réponds sous
amendements parce que c'est tout à fait
important
madame Lubin propose
d'appeler ça contrat de dernier embauche
je crois qu'on aille mis un avis
défavorable à la commission mais
franchement si ça peut nous réunir qu'on
appelle contrat senior ou dernier
embauche ça correspond à ça ça peut être
l'intitulé
deux derniers embauches donc là aussi
les partenaires sociaux définiront la
façon dont ils veulent l'appeler
franchement j'ai aucun état d'âme
là-dessus mais ça rejoint notre
préoccupation parce que c'est celle que
nous avions définies lors du rapport que
nous avions fait sur l'emploi des
seniors donc c'est tout à fait important
en ce qui concerne Olivier nos Olivier
etnot nous propose effectivement de
déterminer un âge différent alors déjà
monsieur le ministre des comptes sociaux
et des comptes de l'État nous disent que
ça coûte cher à 60 ans Alors j'ai pas
osé franchement
envisagé qu'on puisse le mettre à partir
de 55 ans bien entendu ce seront des
partenaires sociaux qui selon les
branches nous dirons quel âge il faut
mettre voyez ça n'ajustement c'est pas
d'ici de niveau du Parlement qu'on va
définir tout cela on a véritablement une
négociation qui peut s'instaurer par
branche et peut-être que on peut
comprendre que c'est un âge différent
selon le type de métier l'usure la
pénibilité on aura l'occasion de le
définir c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai mis un avis défavorable en ce qui
concerne effectivement
je crois que c'est
je ne sais plus qui excusez-moi non
c'est aussi Monique Monique Rubin
jusque 70 ans oui 70 ans c'est le seuil
c'est toi je crois 70 ans c'est le seuil
actuel
d'emploi où on peut effectivement
définir une rupture
unilatérale demandée par l'employeur
pour mise à la retraite avec des
conditions bien spécifiques en ce qui
concerne les cotisations le forfait
social qui est adapté à ce type de
prestation avant 70 ans si l'employeur
ne souhaite rompre avec son employé sa
dispositif de licenciement classique ou
une rupture conventionnelle
c'est un frein il faut bien reconnaître
aujourd'hui savoir quand vous avez des
seniors qui peuvent rester jusqu'à 70
ans parce que ça dépend du salarié quand
il peut partir à la retraite il prévient
je pars à la retraite sauf que s'il ne
veut pas partir à la traite
effectivement nombre d'entreprises nous
disent on est contraint de par la loi de
les garder jusqu'à 70 ans et en
conséquence en conséquence ça peut poser
un problème quand vous embauchez un
seigneur vers 60 60 ans
et beaucoup d'entreprises
hésitent parce que
voyez-vous on peut comprendre que donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut un
contrat spécifique incitatif pourront se
fera à l'emploi parce que compte tenu de
la longévité il faut vraiment qu'il y
ait cette prise de conscience et pour
que elle soit véritablement collective
et ben donnons des outils pour aider à
prendre conscience que les seniors ça va
effectivement contenu de la longévidée
peut-être travailler un peu plus
longtemps en tout cas il faut que ça
puisse être ainsi si on veut éviter de
les mettre dans le dispositif chômage et
trop souvent de la précarité en ce qui
concerne les exonérations
pour lequel on a eu deux remarques
particulières oui nous sommes pas fans
des exonérations et mais cependant
cependant cependant
exonération familiale la branche famille
contrairement à ce que nous
contrairement merci madame la Présidente
contrairement à ce que nous demandions
rappelez-vous nous pensions que nous
pourrions avoir un regard voyez ça nous
est le permis de voir les choses un
petit peu différemment mais les
exonérations mes chers collègues
on peut se les permettre quand on a une
assiette assez importante pour les
cotisations la France ne produit pas
assez c'est bien notre difficulté c'est
pour ça que nous avons une base annonce
commerciale négative il faut élargir la
base de cotisations et cette réforme va
dans ce sens-là et à ce moment-là si
vous avez élargi votre base de
cotisation les exonérations prennent une
dimension tout à fait différente
je pense avoir répondu à toutes les
interrogations qui a été traduite à
travers tous ces amendements merci alors
la vie du gouvernement à la fois sur
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary
au nom de la commission sociale
et puis sur les sous-amendements merci
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Monsieur et Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nous sommes venus à deux
avec mon collègue mis des Lego compte
public pour tenter de résister aux
assauts de monsieur le rapporteur et de
la commission des affaires sociales donc
si vous voulez bien monsieur le
Président je répondrai sur les aspects
qui relèvent du code du travail et
peut-être que mon collègue pourra
répondre sur le la partie du coup
éclairer l'assemblée concernant ce
contrat nous avons à ce stade trois
interrogations deux attentes et une
crainte que je partage avec vous les
trois interrogations quant à la mise en
oeuvre du contrat proposé par la
Commission des affaires sociales
concernent d'une part le principe
d'égalité avec la difficulté lorsqu'on
crée des bornes d'âge sur l'accès à une
contrat de travail d'une nature
spécifique le risque qu'il y ait des
effets de seuil des effets d'aubaine et
des effets de distorsion la deuxième
interrogation concerne le ciblage de cet
outil et nous souhaiterions voir s'il
est possible d'aller vers un ciblage en
termes de bénéficiaires concernant
plutôt les demandeurs d'emploi que
l'ensemble des seniors pour éviter
prévenir toute forme d'effets d'auben et
puis évidemment nous souhaitons puisque
j'ai évoqué ce terme d'effet de Ben
veillez à ce que la différence entre le
CDI de droit commun et ce nouvel outil
qui pourrait s'adresser au Seigneur soit
une différence particulièrement marquée
je donne bien volontiers actes sur le
rapporteur d'un certain nombre de
discussions de modifications notamment
dans la rédaction de l'amendement pour
envoyer une concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux puisque nous
considérons et c'est là l'occasion pour
moi de venir sur les deux points qui
sont des attentes que le gouvernement
exprime à cette occasion nous
considérons qu'il y aurait d'une part un
intérêt à ce que cette mesure soit créée
de nature avec nature dans un premier
temps expérimental et d'autre part nous
considérons que ce CDI propre senior
relève d'un article que monsieur le
Président du Sénat connais bien
l'article la partie dite L1 du code du
travail et qui cela doit renvoyer à une
concertation interprofessionnelle là où
nous avons encore un écart dans la
rédaction la préparation de ce
dispositif avec monsieur le rapporteur
c'est que le gouvernement considère
qu'il y aurait lieu de renvoyer la
totalité des paramètres et de la
définition du nouveau contrat un décret
faisant suite à une concertation
interprofessionnelle alors que la
rédaction de l'amendement prévoit à ce
stade une écriture plus précise sans
toutefois exonéré le gouvernement d'une
obligation de concertation
interprofessionnelle selon ce sont là
les trois points que je voulais
souligner d'une part des interrogations
d'autre part le fait que nous donnons
bien évidemment acte un monsieur le
rapporteur et la commission qu'un
certain nombre de modifications allant
dans le bon sens sont déjà intervenus et
enfin deux points d'attente sur le
caractère expérimental et sur
l'articulation avec le L1 du Code du
travail que je voulais souligner je le
fais monsieur le Président en ayant bien
en tête et Monsieur rapporteur que
lorsque l'article du Code du travail
concernant l'obligation de concertation
interprofessionnelle
a été intégré au code du travail je
crois en 2003 ou 2004 2004 il me semble
sous votre autorité il avait été
explicitement prévu que cette obligation
de concertation interprofessionnelle ne
concernait ni les propositions de loi ni
les amendements mais je crois que
l'esprit et je crois aussi que c'est
partagé que l'esprit prévaut et que il
est utile d'avoir une constatation
interprofessionnelle sur ces sujets là
voilà les remarques qui m'amènent à dire
qu'à à ce stade et en fonction de la
rédaction qui est proposée à cet instant
au Sénat la vie du gouvernement ne peut
pas être favorable et donc par
conséquence il est il est défavorable
mais avec l'espoir que les discussions
et je l'espère les débats que nous
aurons encore cette semaine et ensuite
dans la perspective de la prolongation
du débat parlementaire autour de ce
texte nous puissions trouver un terrain
d'entente
monsieur le ministre Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs je
vous remercie de mettre ce sujet là sur
la table puisque je crois qu'on cherche
tous à réduire le chômage chez les
seniors et à ce titre c'est toujours
intéressant évidemment de discuter des
pistes qui sont proposées moi je suis
toujours assez sceptique sur des
propositions d'allègement de cotisation
ciblées sur un âge donné aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'allaagement de cotisations
liées à un âge il y a des allègements de
cotisation qui sont liés à un type de
contrats qui sont liés à une
rémunération dans les jeunes monsieur
Husson on parle d'allègement sur les
jeunes parce que il y a des allègements
qui sont ciblés sur les niveaux de
salaire au SMIC et que c'est
principalement des jeunes qui sont au
SMIC mais vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez
pas d'allaagement de cotisation lié à un
âge pour une bonne raison à mon avis
c'est que le risque c'est qu'il y a des
effets de seuil si vous dites il y a un
allègement de cotisation pour
l'employeur à partir de 60 ans qu'est-ce
qui va se passer pour les gens qui ont
58 59 ans qui se présentent dans une
entreprise pour être recruté
on va leur dire vous ne coûtez plus cher
que ce que vous me coûterez à 60 ans
donc attendez attendez un an ou deux ans
revenez me voir dans un an ou dans deux
ans quand j'aurai le droit à une
exonération de cotisation parce que vous
avez plus de 60 ans donc le risque c'est
qu'on décale le problème et que c'est
que des personnes qui aujourd'hui en
plus 60 ans et sont au chômage en fait
on décale le problème à ceux qui sont
juste avant 60 ans parce que eux
n'auront pas droit à l'exonération pour
leur employeur s'ils sont recrutés ça
c'est la première chose sur la deuxième
chose c'est un amendement qui coûte
effectivement une certaine somme le
chiffre de 800 millions d'euros c'est
800 millions d'euros si les recrutements
actuels au-delà de 60 ans se font avec
le CDI senior donc on parle d'effet
d'auben c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
vous avez aujourd'hui vous avez en
moyenne 100 000 CDI qui sont signés pour
des personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans par
an
si désormais tous ces CDI signés pour
des personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans
chaque année sont faits avec le nouveau
contrat bah non bah en même temps vous
vous prenez à la vous mettez à la place
d'un employeur vous dites il y a un
nouveau contrat CDI seniors qui existe
avec moins de cotisations il va plutôt
choisir celui-là aujourd'hui vous avez
100000 personnes qui sont recrutées en
CDI après 60 ans si désormais ils sont
tous recrutés avec ce nouveau CDI ça
coûte 800 millions d'euros pour la
branche famille et ça veut dire que la
branche famille se retrouve déficitaire
dès l'année 2025 or j'entends sur tous
les bancs une volonté d'avoir une
politique familiale ambitieuse pour
notamment inciter à la natalité dans
notre pays rejoins cet objectif mais
donc là on se retrouve à dépouiller la
branche famille si on va encore plus
loin sur l'effet d'aubaine ça veut dire
si toutes les personnes qui sont
actuellement en emploi en CDI de plus de
60 ans l'employeur se dit bah en fait
j'ai un allègement de cotisation si je
change de CDI donc on va toutes les
basculer en CDI senior là ça coûte 2
milliards 300 millions d'euros je dis
pas qu'on ira jusque là monsieur le
rapporteur évidemment
mais en tout cas ça veut dire que si
toutes les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui en CDI au-delà de 60 ans
elles sont basculées dans un contrat CDI
seniors ça ferait ça ferait ce coup-là
j'entends que vous souhaitez et
notamment dans la discussion avec les
partenaires sociaux qui est des
garde-fous pour qu'ils puissent pas y
avoir tous ces effets d'aubaine mais en
tout cas le fait est que sur les 100000
recrutement qui a chaque année après 60
ans s'ils sont tous recrutés au CDI
seniors et encore une fois vous mettez à
la place de l'employeur il y a une
baisse de cotisation va plutôt le faire
deuxième chose deuxième chose c'est un
dispositif qui va plutôt favoriser les
hauts revenus les hauts salaires ceux
pour les CE pour qui la question des
cotisations n'est pas l'élément
déterminant pour les employeurs si je
vous donne quelques chiffres pour un
salarié qui a un une rémunération de
4500 euros aujourd'hui vous aurez un
effet maximal de baisse de cotisation
alors même que pour un senior qui a une
rémunération autour de 2000 2500 euros
il y a déjà des allègements de
cotisation notamment avec le bandeau
famille et donc l'effet incitatif serait
le plus fort pour des salariés qui ont
les plus hautes rémunérations pour
lesquelles a priori l'incitation sur les
cotisations n'est pas l'élément
déterminant pour leur recrutement donc
c'est au moins 800 millions d'euros de
coûts pour des salariés et des seniors
donc a priori il y a pas le son pour
lesquels il y a le plus besoin d'un
effet incitatif sur les cotisations donc
moi encore une fois j’allerte sur ce
sujet là il y a des dispositifs un peu
semblables qui ont été testés au niveau
européen et un rapport très intéressant
de France stratégie de 2017 qui dit que
ces dispositifs d'exonération
d'allègement de cotisations ciblées sur
les seniors dans les pays qui l'ont
essayé c'est à dire la Finlande la Suède
et la Hongrie se sont révélés
inefficaces à la fois sur les
recrutements et sur les salaires donc
encore une fois on partage tous le même
objectif moi vous le savez j'ai pas de
tabou sur les allègements de cotisation
les baisses de cotisation je pense que
quand c'est
ça vous le savez non mais vous le savez
donc ça donc ça rend donc ça rend ma
position ça rend ma position d'autant
plus forte et objective moi je pense que
oui oui il y a des exonérations et des
allègements qui sont utiles mais il faut
qu'on soit sûr de leur efficacité en
l'occurrence là je crée un effet
d'aubaine qui met notre branche famille
dans le rouge donc pour ces raisons
défavorables
merci alors nous allons commencer
monsieur Savary vous vouliez ajouter
mille excuses de rallonger un peu le
débat mais je préfère répondre je répète
je préfère répondre tout de suite à
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre
je ne crois pas que vous n'avez pas
compris le dispositif je pense que vous
avez la posture du gardien du temple ce
que je comprends bien du temple
financier je le comprends bien non non
il est pas question que les CDI de 60
ans soient tous pris en compte dans ce
dispositif il est question de proposer
une alternative d'où l'intérêt des
branches de définir dans les branches
l'intérêt de ce CDI non jusqu'à présent
dans les CDI on discute pas d'histoire
d'âge avec avec le salarié tandis que là
ça veut dire que il y a un aspect très
confidentiel jusqu'à présent où le
salarié expose ses conditions de
retraite on regarde sur un faux retraite
les conditions c'est comme un contrat de
chantier donc ça veut dire que par
rapport à ces exonérations de tous les
emplois de 60 ans vous auriez
vous auriez
une embauche supplémentaire de seniors
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça mérite
d'exister alors maintenant vous parlez
d'histoire de bornage pas de bornage moi
je suis mais alors à 100% d'accord avec
vous mais 100% mais pourquoi pourquoi
dans l'article suivant vous nous
proposez des bandages pour les carrières
longues parce qu'effectivement celui qui
a 4 à Sainte trimestre avant la fin de
l'année de l'âge d'un tel mais pas de
peau à chaque fois qu'on a eu des
discussions avec nos collègues ils m'ont
demandé tiens je suis questionné Ah bah
non il a que trois trimestres celui-là
il en a pas 4 à 5 les bordages c'est
terrible c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi on en met mieux c'est mais si on met
pas des bandages dans votre dispositif
monsieur le ministre vous me parlez des
bornes pour le calcul des cotisations
soit les bornes c'est bien soit les
bornes c'est pas bien vous avez mis des
bornes de cotisations différentes
4,5,15 au sud de 3,5 et puis en dessous
un taux différentiel j'en sais rien mais
des bornes effectivement ça devient
incontournable quoi donc soyons
attentifs la CSG c'est déborde et là ça
veut dire effectivement vous me coûtez
trop cher donc finalement je vais vous
payer moins cher comme ça j'ai une
cotisation qui est en dessous donc on
voit bien que tout ça faut revoir le
dispositif alors soyez une volonté
d'accepter le dispositif soit il y a
effectivement il y a la volonté de pas
l'accepter et mes chers collègues je
vous incite plutôt à aller dans le sens
de la Commission de façon à donner
davantage d'espoir au seniors merci
nous allons donc
voter d'abord les sous amendements pour
le bon ordre oui oui non non vous pouvez
expliquer votre vote et aucun problème
et je vais et je signale que je suis
saisi du demande de scrutin public sur
l'amendement de la commission présentée
par les rapporteurs le 21 12 qui aura
lieu à la fin de l'examen des sous
amendements pour le bon ordre de nos
débats
alors madame lui va
merci monsieur le président
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi on est
toujours obligé de faire des cadeaux aux
entreprises pour que elle recrute des
gens soit c'est des jeunes soit c'est
des seniors soit c'est finalement et
alors les entreprises recrutent qui des
gens qui ont entre 25 et 55 ans et puis
après avant ça va pas après ça va plus
moi j'aurais préféré que l'on me demande
de juste aux entreprises en fonction de
certains critères de recruter ou de
maintenir un emploi des seniors pour
qu'elle puisse garder les diverses
exonérations auxquelles elles ont déjà
droit
on n'aurait pas eu besoin d'en rajouter
on leur demanderait un effort par
rapport à ce à quoi elles ont déjà droit
nous nous avons fait aussi par exemple
une proposition
de d'un recrutement ou enfin ou plutôt
de la présence d'un minimum de 15 % ou
d'un plancher de 15% de seniors dans les
entreprises
en gérant le flux c'est à dire soit on
ne se débarrasse pas des gens de plus de
55 ans et lorsqu'on a des postes à
pourvoir on ne on ne on ne comment dire
on ne se prive pas des candidatures de
gens de plus de 55 ans ça aurait déjà
été un bon me semble-t-il une bonne
proposition puis la dernière des
remarques elle est générale elle est
d'ordre général le Medef qui a été
auditionné et que nous avions eu aussi
l'occasion d'auditionner avec René Paul
Savary le Medef est particulièrement
favorable à ce projet de report de l'âge
de recul de l'âge de la retraite et dans
le même temps
il y est favorable mais il refuse
catégoriquement de faire des efforts en
matière de recrutement des gens de plus
de 50 ans voilà donc j'ai envie de dire
ça devient un petit peu pénible quand
même et à un moment il faudra bien
trouver un moyen et moi je le propose
c'est au travers des exonérations déjà
existantes et je vais terminer en disant
que j'ai lu dans la presse ce matin que
le gouvernement je vous donne de la TVA
là
on
allait une pleine de choses au printemps
moi j'aurais aimé qu'on pense automne
c'est à dire qu'on nous propose une loi
travail avant une loi retraite monsieur
chanterelle et chacun respecte bien son
temps
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le rapporteur Savary vous aurez
dû renommer votre amendement
l'amendement Medef parce que c'est c'est
une commande directe du Medef cette
mesure va dans le bon sens a déclarer
Éric chevet le vice-président de la CPME
on n'est pas étonné de sa réaction parce
que avec ce CDI senior vous allez
permettre au patron d'être exonéré des
cotisations familles c'est à dire 5% du
salaire brut tout de même au passage le
ministre des comptes publics monsieur
Attal qui lui n'est pas là pour faire
une réforme de gauche mais pour serrer
la vis vous êtes à l'armée justement du
coup pour les finances publiques 800
millions d'euros
on se demande bien ce qui va rester des
économies prévues soit disant par la
réforme avec le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite mais veut revenons à la
proposition du rapporteur pourquoi donc
des honorations de cotisation famille
quel rapport avec l'emploi des sonneurs
aucun si ce n'est d'en profiter pour
siphonner la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale redevenu excédentaire
en 2021 non en fait c'est parce que
Monsieur ça varie n'a pas eu le choix de
son propre aveu dans une entrevue que
vous avez donné à Ouest-France vous avez
dit il aurait été plus judicieux de
proposer une exonération de cotisations
chômage et oui mais la réforme des
retraites passe par un projet de loi
rectificatif de financement de la
sécurité sociale et l'assurance chômage
est en dehors de ce cadre voilà sur la
forme le résumé de toute l'absurdité du
débat que nous sommes en train d'avoir
mais sur le fond avec ce CDI dérégulé et
à bas coût que va-t-il se passer on
risque de mettre en concurrence des
seniors avec les jeunes sur le seul
critère du coût du travail or les jeunes
eux-mêmes ont aussi beaucoup de mal à
s'insérer c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur saberet nous voterons contre
votre amendement je suis gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues moi je
voudrais d'abord remercier le rapporteur
Savary puisque avec cet amendement il me
rappelle ma jeunesse où je me suis
engagé en 2006 contre le contrat
première embauche et nous avions obtenu
le retrait comme nous obtiendrons le
retrait je le sais de cette réforme des
retraites et je trouve l'expression d'un
collègue Lubin très fort à propos le
contrat dernier embauche bon
premièrement
on a d'abord les effets
quand on a reporté l'âge légal de 60 à
62 ans ça a été nul sur l'embauche des
seniors qui n'était pas au travail nul
et donc les 1 million quatre de
personnes qui sont entre 53 et 69 ans
qui sont aujourd'hui sans emploi ni
revenus il y aura pas plus d'embauche
avec ce contrat dernier embauche
premièrement la deuxième l'argument de
du ministral est fort à propos là aussi
c'est qu'on va signer la branche famille
des cotisations sociales et on va la
sécher donc je n'y reviens pas c'est
mieux quand c'est lui qui le dit plutôt
que le groupe communiste dernière chose
les exonérations de cotisations là on va
avoir un point divergent avec évidemment
monsieur le ministre
on a déjà quand même un certain nombre
de choses pour les évaluer par exemple
cice qui s'est transformé en exonération
de cotisation je lis le rapport France
stratégie le dernier en date 2020 les
résultats restent conformes aux
conclusions des années précédentes un
fort effet emploi est trouvé chez le
quart des entreprises les plus
bénéficiaires du cice qui ne
représentent qu'un huitième des
effectifs mais rien ne significatif chez
les autres l'effet total reste estimé à
5000 emplois nous en avait promis un
million à l'époque ce qui est faible
rapporté au coût du cice de l'ordre de
18 milliards 18 milliards pour 5000
emplois ça fait 180000 euros pour chaque
emploi qu'on sait que ça a l'air médian
est aux alentours de 33000 euros chargé
donc vous voyez ça ne marchera toujours
pas je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Madame Brulin
[Musique]
mes chers collègues c'est vrai que ce
contrat en a envie de l'appeler dernière
embauche pour les raisons que viennent
de rappeler Monique Lubin et Fabien gay
mais je suis pas davantage d'accord avec
le fait qu'on en dise que c'est un CDI
parce que un contrat dont on connaît
l'âge de début et l'âge de faim ça
ressemble quand même beaucoup plus à un
CDD qui a un CDI
enfin les exonérations effectivement
sur la branche femme vous nous avez
expliqué monsieur le rapporteur que
votre préférence aurait été à des
exonérations chômage tout ça confirme
qu'on est quand même de plus en plus
dans du bricolage autour de cette
réforme et c'est ça n'est pas sans nous
inquiéter et puis ça donne quand même
l'impression que certains ici ne
supportent pas qu'une branche de notre
système de protection sociale soit
excédentaire la branche famille enfin
mes chers collègues on va entendre un
peu différemment tout ce que vous allez
nous dire prochainement sur ce que vous
voulez faire en direction des familles
quand dès que vous en avez l'occasion
vous diminuez les recettes pour la
branche famille on pourrait dire la même
chose de la branche accident du travail
maladie professionnelle qui elle aussi
est devenue excédentaire et qui à la
faveur de cette réforme va se voir aussi
spolier un certain nombre de ressources
on a bien compris monsieur le ministre
que les exonérations de cotisation
n'étaient pas tabou pour vous c'est même
malheureusement quasiment la seule
solution que vous mettez en avant à
quasiment chaque problème or il y a des
exonérations de cotisations qui se sont
multipliées pour les basses à l'air ce
qui a contribué à tirer les salaires
vers le bas qui des salaires qui sont
plutôt d'ailleurs le fait de début de
carrière et aujourd'hui on en prend
argument pour dire bah il faudrait aussi
des exonérations de cotisations pour les
fins de carrière parce que sinon ils
sont plus concurrentiels avec les débuts
de carrière et puis ensuite on va nous
dire bah écoutez pour tous les autres il
va falloir aussi des exonérations et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à la
situation que connaît notre financement
de la protection sociale nous proposons
de prendre le chemin exactement inverse
madame Bocquet
monsieur Bocquet c'est Madame briquet
auquel je pensais non non j'ai aucun
doute on va bien de chez le président
les semaines se suivent et de se
ressemblent pas la semaine dernière nous
combintions pieds à pied une aspiration
une réforme d'aspiration libérale votre
choix est depuis hier le monde a changé
nous grâce à la presse nous apprenons
que nous contestons désormais une
réforme de gauche ce matin
je voulais partager avec vous ce
sentiment mes chers collègues sentiment
très étrange pour le groupe communiste
en attendant ce contrat de fin de
carrière censé favoriser l'embauche des
seniors s'appuie sur un seul argument
d'attractivité cela a été dit par mes
collègues l'exonération des cotisations
familiales de l'employeur exonération
que nous combattons parce que elles ont
le fâcheuse inconvénient de créer du
déficit de d'affaiblir les recettes d'un
régime et donc nous combattons pieds à
pied cette logique là alors pensons
sérieusement améliorer le taux d'emploi
des seniors qui est je le rappelle de
56% pour les 55 64 ans en exonérant les
employeurs d'une cotisation actuellement
fixée à
3,45%, soit une économie de 129 euros
sur un salarié payé à 3745 euros vous
pensez résoudre la question des seniors
licenciés à 59 ans en baissant de 60
euros les cotisations des entreprises
sur un salaire médian qui franchement
croira à cette femme
monsieur le Président rénal
oui merci monsieur le Président et bien
comment dire j'ai eu le plaisir ce matin
d'être d'accord pour la première fois
avec des deux ministres présents et
j'allais dire sur l'ensemble des
arguments me semble-t-il bon
et voyez-vous je crois monsieur le
rapporteur je vous crois de bonne foi je
le dis dans votre recherche d'une
solution mais ensuite la bonne foi
n'excuse pas le fait qu'il faut entendre
des choses qui sont vraies et qui sont
me semble-t-il tout à fait justifiés
l'effet d'aubaine
bon ben ça ça existe toujours il y a
même un effet domaine qui pourrait être
encore plus plus terrible ça serait de
licencier un an avant et ensuite de
réembaucher selon un nouveau contrat pas
les mêmes personnes mais d'autres
personnes donc si vous voulez on connaît
les pratiques de certaines entreprises
c'est pas tous les chefs d'entreprise
heureusement mais de certains
entreprises qui jouent effectivement sur
les effets d'aubaine et nous les
connaissons
l'exonération famille j'y reviens pas
c'est curieux de proposer l'exonération
de famille mais vous l'avez expliqué
c'était pas votre objectif mais voilà et
puis leur envoi à la négociation
interprofessionnelle c'est du bon sens
c'est du bon sens ou la vie d'ailleurs
vous-même il faut y revenir mais sur
levenir laissons le venir de la
négociation interprofessionnelle
laissons chercher les solutions au
niveau au niveau des branches je pense
que c'est comme ça bon donc pour moi le
sujet numéro un d'ailleurs c'est pas
celui-là c'est d'abord de conserver les
seniors qui sont au travail avant de
savoir comment on réembauche comment
dans les entreprises on maintient les
gens au travail jusqu'à à l'âge à la fin
de l'âge légal au minimum
donc moi je vous demanderai au vu de ce
qui s'est dit et de ce qui s'est dit de
manière à tout à fait correcte
je vous remercierai monsieur le
rapporteur de considérer que vous avez
fait oeuvres utile que vous avez déposé
un amant de la bande d'appel et que
maintenant au vu de ce qui s'est dit
très logiquement vous le retirez Madame
A pour ce poly
monsieur le Président alors
nous nous opposons évidemment fermement
à cet amendement des rapporteurs nous
avons déjà bien du mal à trouver je vous
le rappelle de l'emploi et un CDI pour
les jeunes et vous n'avez vous pour
ligne de mire que de tirer ambulance à
savoir évidemment exploiter jusqu'à la
dernière force des seigneurs et puis
vous avez certainement reçu évidemment
les félicitations du Medef pour votre
belle amendement parce qu'il le réclame
à corps et accrit vous nous assumez de
cette réforme est une réforme de justice
sociale pourtant il s'agit bien l'autre
casser encore plus nos Seigneur avant
même de vous parler du droit au repos ou
comme vous aimez l'appeler ici dans
cette hémicycle le droit à la paresse
nous vous rappelons que le droit
fondamental au respect de la vie privée
familiale que vous torpillez que cela
soit avec la réforme mais également avec
cet amendement déconnecté complètement
déconne de la réalité du travail de la
durée de la dure réalité du labeur des
salariés de ce pays pour bien
détrailleurs à chaque jour suffit sa
peine et par cet amendement vous
souhaitez nous vendre comme de mauvais
publicitaires que vous êtes l'idée selon
laquelle nos seniors n'attendent qu'une
seule chose continuez continuer à
travailler mes chers collègues c'est
amendement ne parle à personne si ce
n'est qu'au patron vous vous détachez de
la réalité de millions de Français de
celle de millions de travailleurs
précaires pour favoriser une foi encore
les mêmes et vous envisagez de les
choyer de surcroît en les exonération de
cotisations sociales ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il est absolument contre-productif de
recruter des personnes qui sont cusées à
des postes qui nécessitent motivation et
à endurance votre amendement contrevient
à toute forme de pertinence et
d'humanité nous voterons contre
merci monsieur jaumier
merci Monsieur président écoutez ce
dispositif au moins un mérite c'est
comme il comporte une disposition sur
les cotisations sociales et les
conformes à une LSS ce qui est pas le
cas de tous les articles donc il faut
quand même le noter pour le reste le
rapporteur a fait un lien intéressant
d'ailleurs à souvenir entre la
production et les exonérations de
cotisation moi je veux dire j'ai regardé
les résultats ils sont pas flagrants
franchement depuis que cette politique
est devenue massive notamment depuis
on peut pas dire que la balance
commerciale de la France se soit
vraiment amélioré c'est fortement
dégradé et nos capacités de production
sont pas fortement en hausse c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire ça euphémisme
donc la question qui se pose c'est que
ces exonérations de cotisation surtout
elles sont un phénomène permanent de
modification de la dépense publique dans
notre pays et c'est là où ce projet de
loi retraite a aussi un versant qui est
intéressant on transfère toujours plus
d'argent vers les entreprises la dépense
publique c'est une baisse des dépenses
en faveur des services publics et les
gens ils le voient partout autour d'eux
c'est pas la peine de répéter la justice
où elle en est la santé etc
c'est des dépenses vers les ménages et
là on y est au coeur avec la question
des retraites et c'est du transfert vers
les entreprises et quand on passe de
2018 à 2023 de 38 à 73 milliards d'euros
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
et qu'on augmente massivement les
transfert vers les entreprises il faut
bien prendre l'argent quelque part alors
on le prend sur les services publics qui
sont à l'os et quand même partout dans
nos départements c'est la catastrophe et
on le prend maintenant sur le transfert
vers les ménages là en voulant récupérer
de l'argent sur le système de retraite
alors tout ça est un choix politique
très clair mais il faut l'assumer
maintenant il faut l'assumer et je suis
heureux qu'une part oui oui dans votre
camp chez les républicains il y a des
députés qui ouvrent les yeux et qui
disent ça suffit on ne peut plus aller
dans ce sens là Monsieur Hénault
oui merci monsieur le Président violé
ministre d'abord une remarque monsieur
chanterelle a dit tout à l'heure que
monsieur le rapporteur répondait à une
commande du Medef je trouve cette
remarque désobligeante déplacée et ça
vous grandit pas voilà et comme vous
êtes coutumier du fait je voulais le
faire ce matin je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr sur cette question sur cette
amendement nous avons un doute sur le
risque d'effet d'aubaines
nous avons naturellement ce doute moi
j'avoue que s'il y avait pas eu
l'article 40 d'ailleurs sans doute que
j'aurais déposé un amendement plutôt sur
une prime que sur une exonération ceci
dit j'ai été sensible aux arguments du
du rapporteur sur les partenaires
sociaux et la négociation raison pour
laquelle je retire mes deux sous
amendements et je pense que on fait un
pari parce que si on si on augmente pas
la quantité de travail et la quantité
des seniors au travail bien évidemment
alors je suis sensible à l'argument de
Madame Rossignol et au risque
d'affaiblir le financement de la branche
famille mais on fait un pari et ce Paris
nous devons le faire d'augmenter le taux
de travail de des seniors pour financer
notre système de retraite par
répartition je pense d'ailleurs et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je retire ces
deux sous amendements
ils nous devons chaque fois que nous le
pouvons laisser le plus de l'attitude
possible à la négociation des
partenaires sociaux c'est l'état
d'esprit qui est celui de notre groupe
si nous voulons aussi redonner du gras à
moudre et faire en sorte qu'on ait un
pariarisme refondé et rénové et ce sera
une dépression de de la loi travail à
venir je vous remercie merci monsieur
brollier
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur du
ministre chers collègues j'ai commencé
par un point d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire monsieur Hainaut je pense
qu'effectivement il s'agit d'un chantier
qui devrait être ouvert avec les
partenaires sociaux dans la négociation
interprofessionnelle avant de venir en
débat parmi nous bien sûr il y a un
énorme problème du travail des seniors
nous l'avons d'ailleurs évoqué
longuement hier à propos de l'index pour
lequel il y a un refus de toute mesure
contraignante
ce chantier devrait donc être ouvert
avec les partenaires sociaux et je veux
dire un point d'accord avec le ministre
Attal aussi sur les critiques qu'il fait
du dispositif un point d'accord
notamment lorsqu'il critique les mesures
de bornes
mais j'ai espéré qu'il y avait pas de à
c'était pas les mesures de bornes alors
c'est moi qui est qui est
j'avais mal compris monsieur le ministre
j'ai pensé qu'il pouvait y avoir un
sous-entendu donc c'était juste les
mesures d'âge pardon mais effectivement
il peut y avoir un effet de bornes ou de
seuil avec une mesure comme celle-là et
notamment qui impacterait les gens âgés
de 58 59 ans dans la question de l'accès
à l'emploi et tout aussi importante et
puis enfin dernière remarque on parle
toujours d'exonération et ensuite on
parle toujours des déficits de
l'ensemble des caisses publiques donc
comme l'a évoqué un collègue et je
m'excuse de ne pas le citer avant moi je
suggère effectivement qu'on diminue pour
inciter les entreprises embauchées
peut-être dans le cadre de l'index qu'on
diminue les très nombreuses exonérations
qui leur sont accordés à celles qui ne
respectent pas le taux d'emploi des
seniors ou et qu'on les maintiennent à
celles qui embauche en tous les cas
qu'on
souligne l'intérêt de maintenir ces
exonérations uniquement pour ceux qui
embauchent réellement ou qui servent les
enjeux climatiques
monsieur le Président Retailleau
moi je considère que
l'amendement de René Paul Savary que
nous allons voter évidemment
révèle un enjeu qui est un des plus
grand de cette réforme parce que à quoi
servirait-il d'augmenter de reculer
l'âge légal de départ si on ne fait rien
sur l'emploi des seniors vous savez
parfaitement que le taux de chômage et
un certain nombre de sénatrices et de
sénateurs de l'opposition l'ont répété
hier touche tout particulièrement les
seniors et nous nous contentons pas de
ce que nous dit le gouvernement le
gouvernement dit mais nous on a un outil
extraordinaire
c'est l'index l'index est une
statistique certes il y aura l'effet
diamondshine en bon vendéen pardon mais
ça n'est pas suffisant nous voulons
trouver un autre outil et c'est ce qu'a
fait la commission la commission nous a
dit on peut peut-être trouver à travers
ce nouveau contrat qui va s'adresser à
des seniors un outil qui permettra de
lutter contre le chômage des seniors
vous faites plusieurs reproches je vais
y répondre René Paul Savary a répondu au
reproches de la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux il y a trois
reproches essentiellement vous ne dites
un effet d'auben oui il y aurait eu un
effet d'aubaine si le contrat
s'adressait au plus de 60 ans qui sont
déjà dans l'entreprise non là ça ne sera
pas le cas ce sera des gens qu'on va
sortir du chômage et qui vont rentrer
sur le marché du travail première chose
et vous savez parfaitement parfaitement
qu'on embauche très très peu en France
après 60 ans donc il y a pas d'effets
d'aubaine il y a pas d'effet double
deuxième reproche que vous faites sur le
coup nous contestons formellement nous
contestons formellement le coût du
gouvernement nous le contestons parce
que le gouvernement
ne regarde qu'une ligne la ligne de la
dépense mais il s'agit d'activer en
réalité des dépenses chômage
d'indemnisation et il s'agit de faire en
sorte que des gens qui bénéficient
bénéficier parce qu'ils ont un emploi
des économies sont chiffrés ce à quoi
revient par exemple 100 000 seniors qui
ont réintègre sur le marché du travail
c'est près d'un milliard donc vous voyez
que c'est une mesure qui à notre sens ne
coûtera pas mais au contraire rapportera
et troisième élément troisième reproche
que vous avez fait ça va assécher la
branche famille non puisque pour
l'instant ils sont au chômage il y a pas
de cotisation famille donc il s'agit
encore une fois et c'est l'esprit
d'ailleurs de la réforme de réactiver et
de faire en sorte le dos d'activités
madame le héros
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
vous proposez d'instaurer un nouveau
type de contrat de travail afin de
favoriser l'emploi d'un seigneur mais la
question n'est pas de créer un nouveau
CDI mais que les entreprises gardent
leur salarié de 55 ans et plus votre
proposition risque de mettre en
concurrence des seniors avec les jeunes
sur le seul critère du coup du travail
sachant que les jeunes aussi ont du mal
à s'insérer vous exonérer les
entreprises de cotisation familiales
donc vous ponctionnez ça vient d'être
dit les caisses d'allocations familiales
la protection sociale de nos familles or
nous savons que cette politique
familiale a besoin de moyens pour mettre
en place un vrai service public de la
petite enfance il nous manque des places
en crèche nous avons besoin de moyens
pour financer les congés pour l'égalité
femme homme soit une soit en réalité
tout simplement le l'égalité
professionnelle qui passe aussi par une
égalité des droits des deux parents à
accompagner l'arrivée de l'enfant dans
le foyer
nous avons besoin de cotisations pour
compenser les congés de maternité alors
que les femmes pour que les femmes et
les mêmes droits au départ à la retraite
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre du socle
avec le la première ministre vous
considériez initialement que les
exonérations de cotisation n'était pas
le meilleur moyen pour agir sur l'emploi
des seniors alors quels sont les
éléments qui vous ont fait changer
d'avis il serait intéressant pour nous
de les connaître pour notre part nous ne
changeons pas d'avis le meilleur moyen
de maintenir les seigneurs en emploi
jusque 62 ans et de ne pas changer l'âge
légal de départ nous savons déjà que un
salarié sur deux n'est pas en emploi sur
la tranche d'âge des 50-64 ans de 55 64
ans merci Madame Ferré
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
revenir sur la question du véhicule
législatif vous allez me dire encore et
toujours oui encore et toujours parce
que à nouveau avec cette article
additionnel et bien on voit que le
véhicule législatif que le gouvernement
a choisi n'est pas le bon vous avez dit
je vais revenir sur les propos de
Monsieur le rapporteur il aurait été
plus judicieux de proposer une
exonération de cotisation chômage dans
la mesure où l'embauche de seigneur
réduit le chômage oui mais problème nous
sommes dans une loi de finances
rectificative et l'assurance chômage
étant dehors de ce cadre alors oui ce
véhicule législatif ne décidément pas le
bon s'agissant des exonérations et la
proposition qui est faite d'exonérer au
travers de ce CDI comme ma collègue je
m'interroge CDI c'est qu'on n'est pas de
fin quand on ne connaît pas la fin là on
la connaît cette date de fin puisque
c'est la date de départ en retraite de
la personne qui serait recrutée donc
plutôt de ce CDD monsieur le ministre
vous vous je vous dis les exonérations
de cotisations ne sont pas le meilleur
moyen pour développer l'emploi des
seigneurs des seigneurs pour moi pardon
pour moi ce n'est pas le meilleur moyen
c'est ça n'est pas le moyen pour
développer l'emploi des seniors c'est
effectivement monsieur atteint le
ministre que vous avez dit que le coût
de cet amendement serait de 800 millions
d'euros c'est pas rien c'est pas rien
tout comme si on additionne et si on
regarde l'ensemble du coup ou l'ensemble
des exonérations employeurs qui sont de
l'ordre de 80 milliards d'euros alors
cessons de faire des propositions qui
pourraient convenir plutôt et je le dis
moi aussi sans complexe et en assumant
complètement ce que je dis qui sont de
véritables cadeaux aux entreprises ce
sont d'être dans cette volonté d'aider
les entreprises et non pas celles et
ceux qui sont sans emploi parce que
aussi le risque est réel de mettre en
concurrence les seniors et les jeunes
avec ce seul critère du coût du travail
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
merci monsieur le Président je n'imagine
pas que cet amendement puisse être autre
chose qu'un amendement d'appel et je
voudrais faire quelques remarques
d'abord au ministre qui nous dit j'ai
pas de tabou sur les exonérations
sociales
oui un peu quand même vous en avez
monsieur le ministre parce que 75
milliards annuels d'exonération de
charges sociales et un discours
permanent sur les déficits publics mais
jamais aucun lien n'est fait entre le
montant le volume des exonérations de
charge sociale et le montant des
déficits publics pour autant il y en a
un et celui-là il est toujours dans le
tabou puisque vous n'en parlez pas
deuxième remarque c'est que
vous monsieur Savary et je pense que
vous êtes sincère quand vous le dites
vous renvoyez à la négocié à la
consultation des partenaires sociaux
permettant de vous dire que en ce moment
sur la consultation des partenaires
sociaux à l'initiative de ce
gouvernement on est pour le moins
prudent sur la nature de cette
concertation et ce que les partenaires
sociaux pourraient obtenir comme
garantie dans une négociation avec le
gouvernement qui a décidé de ne plus de
s'émanciper de la vie des partenaires
sociaux en matière de politique sociale
parce que dans cet amendement moi j'ai
pas tout compris mais peut-être que
peut-être j'ai pas été assez comment
dire rigoureuse ou attentive vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que l'employeur
s'engage à garder le salarié nonobstant
l'ensemble de toutes les autres règles
du Code du travail concernant le
licenciement par exemple je n'imagine
pas qu'il s'agisse d'un engagement qui
émancie qui protège le travailleur dans
toutes les circonstances donc comment ça
s'articule avec le licenciement habituel
pour faute pour licenciement économique
plan social à ce moment là il y a plus
d'engagement donc là on a besoin quand
même je crois de retravailler un peu et
puis tout à l'heure le président
Retailleau nous a dit que à la fois que
il voyait pas bien enfin qu'il y avait
un lien entre cet amendement et le recul
d'âge et puis notre collègue Olivier
Hainaut a dit que c'était un pari alors
moi j'aime bien que les paris soit
équitables il y a ça c'est un pari mais
le recul d'âge dans l'esprit du
gouvernement c'est pas un pari c'est un
coup près qui va qui va qui
s'appliquerait de la loi merci Monsieur
fichier
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre c'est juste une précision
parce que Corinne Ferrer en a fait état
tout à l'heure on parle de CDI mais en
fait c'est un CDD dont il s'agit d'un
CDD de 4 ans puisqu'il sera signé à
l'âge de 60 ans et à 64 ans c'est
terminé il y a donc il y a une sorte de
CDD vieux ou de contrats de dernière
embauche en fait en plus on ne peut pas
comprendre le fait que ça s'arrête à 64
heures puisque si les personnes
souhaitent aller jusqu'à 70 ans ce n'est
que mieux puisque c'est même personne
pendant ce temps-là démarreront pas aux
caisses de retraite donc autant
d'économie de fait je crois que du coup
ça vaut le coup d'y réfléchir je vous
remercie et Madame meunier
c'est le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues tout d'abord
moi je voudrais dire que je me réjouis
de la tonalité de nos propos et de la
belle qualité des débats ce matin ça
augure je pense d'une belle semaine à
venir
monsieur Savary le rapporteur Savary
vous avez dit vous-même que par cet
amendement qui n'est qu'un outil nouveau
c'est ainsi que vous l'avez qualifié
certes mais c'est un outil au service
d'une mécanique que nous ne voulons pas
donc désolé mais ne je ne voterai pas
votre amendement monsieur le ministre
Attal vous avez dit que c'était un
risque mais c'est l'ensemble du projet
de loi qui est un risque un risque pour
les personnes qui sont concernées les
plus modestes celles qui ont travaillé
dans des métiers les plus difficiles et
qui verront de fait deux ans
supplémentaires de cotisations avant de
partir à la retraite et puis vous dites
que vous vous n'avez pas de tabous ça a
été souligné tout à l'heure de tabou
concernant les exonérations et ça je
veux bien vous croire par contre vous
avez des tabous concernant les recettes
et les possibilités de recettes
nouvelles nous vous en avons fait de ce
côté de l'hémicycle et vous persistez à
ne pas les entendre la taxation sur les
super profits les contributions sur les
eaux salaires et les grosses fortunes et
toutes celles que nous avons pu aussi
décliner que notre déclinerons tout au
long de ce débat merci merci
monsieur le Président
moi je je rejoins tout à fait ce que
disait tout à l'heure le président
Retailleau si on ne fait rien pour
inciter à l'embauche des seniors on
passe à côté d'un point essentiel c'est
très fort
g auditionné avec le groupe le
professeur Lorenzi président du Cercle
des économistes qui a calculé que si en
France nous rattrapions tout simplement
le déficit dans l'emploi des seniors
rappelle que ces 10 points de déficit
par rapport à la moyenne de l'OCDE ça
rapporterait 13 milliards pour notre
système de retraite 13 milliards
je crois que les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes
d'ailleurs je crois que sur le ministre
dans vos
papiers notamment ceux qui nous ont été
donnés lorsque nous avions fait le bilan
d'étape vous parliez de pour cent mille
emplois créés le Seigneur un milliard de
recettes supplémentaires vous pouvez le
confirmer j'ai imagine aisément je les
élus ce sont des chiffres qui nous
permettent d'envisager et je rejoins
tout à fait la position que
défendait tout à l'heure Olivier et nous
plutôt une prime à l'embauche que des
exonérations
les exonérations on le sait tous les
PLFSS on se plaint des exonérations et
l'État est obligé de compenser les
exonérations depuis le vote de la loi
organique n'est-ce pas monsieur le
ministre donc je crois que le plus
simple ce serait de mettre une prime à
l'embauche
quant à un emploi rapporte enfin 100000
emplois rapportent un milliard on sait
qu'on peut libérer effectivement
quelques centaines de millions pour
pouvoir permettre à des seniors de
retrouver effectivement la dignité du
travail merci
[Applaudissements]
et ensuite ce sera le président Gontard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres je crois que à travers les
discussions que nous avons nous
constatons très bien qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une proposition de loi de gauche plus
on avance plus on se rend compte que
cette proposition est que les
différentes propositions qui sont fait
également notamment celle qui a été
faite par notre rapporteur et bien ne
correspondent pas il faudrait une vraie
loi pour parler de la retraite pour
parler du travail des jeunes des jeunes
et pour parler des seniors parce que là
on est dans la confusion on est dans le
bricolage et ce n'est pas le bon
véhicule pour aller en Guadeloupe je
prends l'avion je ne vais pas prendre
une trottinette donc bien on est dans un
cas de figure qui serait similaire donc
je crois aujourd'hui que nous devons
être sérieux nous devons travailler dans
l'intérêt premier des seniors et là la
façon d'aborder les choses dans
l'appréhender s'apparente à une façon de
les maltraités les
des entreprises parce que les éléments
qui sont évoqués chacun entendu mais
c'est pas normal ce n'est pas normal
parler de la broche famine moi je veux
bien parce qu'il y a beaucoup à faire et
ma collègue vient de discuter de
proposer un certain nombre de pistes
nous ne pouvons pas faire n'importe quoi
nous ne devons pas faire n'importe quoi
dans mon territoire la question des
jeunes se pose beaucoup plus que des
seniors mais les seniors aussi donc nous
devons mettre en oeuvre tout ce qu'il
faut tous les moyens pour une vraie voix
de retraite et ne pas faire n'importe
quoi pour les seniors les maltraités
c'est maltraités les enfants c'est
maltraiter les plus jeunes c'est
maltraiter la société merci
président comptable
se prépare
très rapidement je voulais juste lever
peut-être une petite incohérence parce
que j'ai écouté le président Retailleau
tout à l'heure et
puis j'ai regardé ce qu'il avait pu dire
et dans une belle envolée je crois que
c'était hier sur les bienfaits du recul
de l'âge et il nous disait le recul de
l'âge procure un autre avantage nous
allons automatiquement mécaniquement
augmenter le temps d'emploi des seniors
et ainsi mettre plus de travail dans la
machine et donc je m'étonne un petit peu
que du coup aujourd'hui on nous explique
bah que non justement mécaniquement
automatiquement ça ne fonctionnera pas
mais qu'il faut un dispositif un autre
dispositif peut-être de l'huile du coup
dans la machine pour pouvoir employer
ces seniors donc c'est vrai que là je
vois une petite une petite incohérence
que j'aimerais bien lever parce que ça
me paraît important d'ailleurs tarlin un
de vos collègues nous ont dit si on ne
fait rien on aura tout faux donc voilà
j'aimerais j'aimerais essayer de
comprendre parce que c'est vrai que si
justement ce bien fait de l'âge de recul
à la retraite ces fameux deux ans vont
nous permettre mécaniquement il me
semble que ce dispositif pour le coup ne
sert à rien à moins que ça soit
simplement un faux CDI et simplement une
voie de garage
merci merci monsieur le Président sur le
dispositif qui nous est proposé on ne
peut que contester son existence parce
que le problème c'est sa finalité qu'on
a du mal à percevoir c'est quoi la vraie
finalité de ce contrat qui est un
contrat dont on imagine mal la portée
dans le temps avec toutes les limites
qui ont été qui ont été imposées et puis
on a entendu monsieur le ministre
monsieur Attal nous dire que cette
disposition aurait un effet particulier
puisqu'elle coûte elle coûterait 800
millions d'euros mais je suis un peu
surpris par la dualité du discours parce
que quand il s'agit de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation à peu près 26 milliards
d'euros dont 8 milliards pour les 20%
les les plus les plus aisés quand on
supprime la CVAE là
l'exécutif fait des paris et on n'a pas
du tout de vision sur ce qui vont être
ou ce qui pourrait être les conséquences
c'est des paris par contre quand il est
question d'augmenter même de manière
modérée les recettes sociales pour
financer la protection sociale là ce
n'est plus possible d'en parler il y a
tout un ensemble de solutions qui
existent et que nous vous proposons
régulièrement comme l'augmentation du
taux d'emploi des seniors comme
l'égalité homme-femme comme simplement
comme la montré Tobin Piketty
l'augmentation de 2% de la CSG sur les
hauts patrimoine qui viendrait compenser
l'ensemble des besoins du système de
retraite la vraie question c'est
pourquoi d'un côté vous êtes
relativement timoré et pourquoi de
l'autre il faudrait alors vous faire
confiance
à vos gel
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais aller dans le sens du de mon
collègue Guillaume Gontard pour dire que
nous trouvons ici dans une situation un
peu un peu curieuse on a d'un côté dans
ce côté-là de l'hémicycle des collègues
qui nous disent cette réforme est
nécessaire et elle est très utile
notamment pour l'emploi des seniors
parce automatiquement en augmentant
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite on
va augmenter le nombre de seniors en
emploi et en même temps on nous dit si
on crée part un CDI senior ou peu
importe comment il s'appelle exactement
on passe à côté de l'élément essentiel
de cette réforme qui est absent
aujourd'hui du projet de loi donc déjà
est-ce qu'on pourrait peut-être se
mettre d'accord entre nous sur le fait
de dire que le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite ne crée pas d'emploi chez
les seniors puisque les républicains ont
eux-mêmes déposé un amendement pour
réparer ce qu'ils ont ce qu'il décrivait
comme pourtant étant déjà dans la
réforme ça c'est une première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que bon moi j'avais
pas ces chiffres en tête mais je je
crois bien volontiers notre collègue
vient de nous dire si on avait si on
corrigé l'écart de d'emploi des seniors
en France par rapport à la moyenne de
l'UE on aurait très similiaire dans les
caisses c'est-à-dire en gros bien ce que
ce qu'on cherche c'est de l'ordre de 13
milliards qu'on cherche et on a un
dispositif qu'on nous propose qui
consiste à baisser des cotisations donc
à appauvrir les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale donc on marche sur la tête d'un
côté on nous dit cette réforme va
permettre d'augmenter l'emploi des
seniors mais comme elle ne le fait pas
on a besoin d'un outil qui va nous
permettre que l'emploi des seniors donne
moins dans les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale dont nous avons besoin pour
financer les retraites je veux dire à un
moment donné il y a un aspect de pure
cohérence intellectuelle qui m'échappe
totalement
madame line
on voit bien que cette proposition
d'une part fait le constat du fait que
ça va aggraver la situation des seniors
certes il y aura quelques créations de
prolongement mais le gros du paquet va
rester ni emploi ni
retraite et comme d'habitude la seule
idée qui vient à droite c'est que j'en
ai des cotisations sociales ça fait des
lustres
que vous avez des contrats de ceci
premier embauche dernier machin là ça va
être dernier embauche et l'efficacité je
m'excuse de dire c'est la bulle par
contre l'assèchement des comptes de la
protection sociale ça c'est du sérieux
alors
parlons des cotisations
s'il y avait l'égalité salariale mode
femme qui est peut-être quand même plus
facile à atteindre que de faire
travailler des gens qui pour une part
sont dans des situations très difficiles
pour pouvoir travailler on aurait déjà
fait la moitié de vos 13 milliards là on
en serait à 6 ou 7 deuxièmement ça fait
des années des années qu'on explique que
les exonérations de cotisations sociales
si elles sont elles peuvent être
pertinentes elles ne le peuvent être
qu'à deux conditions la première c'est
qu'elle soit ciblée vers des activités
par exemple pour accompagner la
réindustrialisation l'évolution de la
tension inécologique etc et si elles
sont conditionnées c'est à dire s'il y a
des garanties au lieu de créer le énième
la énième cotisation allégée
exiger que pour avoir l’allègement
l'équivalent c'est du du contrat du
les allégements Hollande contrat bon
bref
c'est voilà merci la contrepartie de
l'équivalent c'est ice soit conditionné
un accord ou à des engagements
concernant toute une série de critères
dont l'augmentation de la part des
seniors là vous ne faites pas dépenses
supplémentaires vous ciblez merci alors
je vais maintenant donner la parole il
n'y a plus de monde d'explication de
vote à Madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues j'ai entendu
parler de concurrence entre les jeunes
et les vieux alors là c'est quelque
chose que que j'ai du mal à entendre
parce que je crois que alors je suis
peut-être idéaliste mais en réalité je
crois à l'utilité de chacun dans la
société il y a pas de mise en
concurrence de telles catégories
vis-à-vis de telle autre je pense qu'on
a dans ce pays parfois penser à des
politiques spécifiques pour les jeunes
on a moins pensé aux politiques
spécifiques pour les seniors c'est
dommage il y a quand même un territoire
le Val-de-Marne qui a pensé et nous
avons auditionné d'ailleurs les acteurs
de ce dispositif qui s'appelle label
plus 45 et c'était très intéressant de
les entendre parce que en réalité on
pourrait déployer ce type de dispositif
un petit peu partout c'est à dire
sensibiliser l'entreprise sensibilité la
population parce que comme je le disais
hier c'est notre société qui doit
changer de mentalité vis-à-vis de nos
aînés les aînés ont des choses à
transmettre les aînés ont des choses à
dire aux jeunes alors que on a de plus
en plus de d'apprentis dans notre dans
nos territoires on devrait justement
capitaliser si c'est un terme qui ne
vous plaît pas moi je pense qu'on peut
capitaliser sur le savoir des anciens et
donc un contrat tel que il est proposé
est aussi sur cette dimension là cette
idéale là de transmettre et de et de
permettre à nos seniors et bien
d'apporter aux jeunes une sorte de
tutorat de Manta qui est utile alors
c'est vrai que ce contrat il est sans
doute pas bien écrit et qui qu'il faut y
repenser mais il y a effectivement une
loi travail qui qui arrive donc on
pourra le travailler ensemble si je puis
dire mais je voudrais reparler aussi de
l'index Seigneur parce que moi il me
semble que dans cette index Seigneur il
faudra penser dans la loi travail à y
mettre un bonus on est toujours à parler
de punir punir punir mais on sait on
peut aussi dire quand c'est bien et
quand on valorise des bonnes initiatives
et donc dans l'index Seigneur et bien il
faudra justement regarder comment on
peut mettre en avant les très bonnes
initiatives et je pense que des CDI vers
les seniors c'est une très belle
initiative
il excuse oui oui je voudrais juste deux
trois près de 6 ans sans allonger les
débats mais elle me semble
indispensable non je ne suis pas
asservie au MEDEF à tel point que
j'accepte bien volontiers l'indicateur
je crois pas que ce soit le Medef qui
réclame l'indicateur mais permettez-moi
de vous dire que
j'ai des relations toujours respectueuse
avec les différents partenaires sociaux
que ce soit le Medef FO j'ai eu
l'occasion de rencontrer auditionné son
secrétaire général je rencontre
régulièrement madame pizza puisqu'elle
est présidente de l'argile Carco et puis
d'autres dans le cadre du corps et
Monique Lubin c'est bien les discussions
qu'on peut avoir au niveau du corps on
évite effectivement de parler ce qu'il
fâche sinon on en sortirait pas une fois
qu'on a dit ça on peut parler d'autre
chose et notamment de l'employabilité
des seniors et c'est comme ça que à
force de discussion est venue cette idée
pas inventé si vous voulez je voulais
remettre un petit peu
ça vous le dire en toute en toute
s'intéressé donc indépendant de tout
cela vous voyez vous j'ai pas
effectivement écouter toutes les
propositions de tout j'en ai choisi
quelques-unes deuxièmement
il a été
dit à travers une intervention que il
fallait plutôt que s'occuper des seniors
au chômage qu'il fallait mieux s'occuper
des seniors en emploi oui aussi les
seigneurs en emploi c'est pour ça que
notamment vous êtes les premiers à
dénoncer ce qu'on dénonce aussi qu'il
faut prendre des mesures pour les maires
de famille et les mesures des mers de
famille qu'on va vous proposer c'est
effectivement parce que elle reste en
emploi un peu plus longtemps peut-être
avec l'effet de décalage de l'âge mais
surtout avec l'effet de la réforme
Touraine
de faire en sorte de vouloir
particulièrement mettre les seniors au
travail c'est l'application de la
réforme Touraine on travaille 43 ans
quand vous voyez vous avez commencé à 20
ans vous travaillez 43 ans mais quand
vous avez commencé à travailler à 22 ans
un vous travaillez jusque Canac jusque
65 ans c'est la réforme Touraine l'effet
d'âge effectivement
il peut avoir aussi un effet mais je
voudrais qu'on soit clair entre nous
très clair entre nous
c'est pas 43 ans plus deux ans du
au travail supplémentaire soi-disant de
62 à 64 non non c'est l'ajustement des
bornes et effectivement de par la
réforme Touraine certains seront ou
certaines seront amenés à travailler
plus longtemps et d'autres par les faits
de l'âge légal seront à travailler
quelques mois également plus longtemps
peut-être
années pour certaines générations mais
c'est pas deux ans de plus pour tout le
monde arrêtez de vendre un argument qui
est faux parce qu'effectivement ça
contribue à mettre les gens dans la rue
mais si on leur explique bien
la différence elle est quand même
importante
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc je ne suis pas le bourreau
des seniors que vous prétendez que je
sois ensuite effectivement il y a eu il
y a eu des propositions de la belle
Jean-Marie un garçon sage Jean-Marie il
connaît bien le dispositif il connaît
bien les syndicats et il est pas le
service non plus un syndicat mais ne
connaît bien ben écoutez moi je partage
aussi ça un index à pénalise un label ça
valorise bon on peut peut-être trouver
un équilibre entre les deux
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement je veux pas contribuer à
allonger les débats je pense qu'on a été
suffisamment éclairé mais je voudrais
répondre à quelques points qui ont été
évoqués qui peuvent je pense être utile
dans les choix que les uns et les autres
feront au moment du vote si l'amendement
n'est pas retiré d'abord pour répondre à
monsieur vandlerenberg je vous rejoins
totalement
sur la question du taux d'emploi si on
avait le même taux d'emploi en France
que nos voisins allemands moi j'aurais
pas de travail j'en aurai beaucoup moins
pour équilibrer les comptes puisque les
recettes supplémentaires induite par 10
points de taux d'emploi en plus nous
permettrait d'équilibrer ou en tout cas
d'équilibrer beaucoup mieux nos budgets
donc la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on améliore le taux d'emploi
améliorer le taux d'emploi ça veut dire
travailler sur les jeunes et c'est donc
tout ce qu'on a fait notamment sur
l'apprentissage ce qu'on doit faire sur
la réforme du lycée professionnel qui
aujourd'hui objectivement ne permet pas
d'insérer véritablement les jeunes dans
l'emploi et donc c'est une réforme qui
est particulièrement importante et deux
sur les seniors et donc oui on doit
s'interroger collectivement sur les
mesures les plus efficaces pour
améliorer le taux d'emploi des seniors
et c'est vrai et je réponds à Madame
Vogel notamment c'est vrai que la
réforme de 2010 a permis une
amélioration du taux d'emploi des
seniors de 15 points depuis 2010 toutes
les études qui ont été réalisées le
disent et il y a pas eu besoin de
contrats spécifiques après la réforme
Fillon de 2010 pour améliorer de 15
points le taux d'emploi des seniors mais
évidemment qu'on doit penser à des
mesures supplémentaires il y a l'index
il peut y en avoir d'autres moi j'ai
entendu le rapporteur général comme
Monsieur Vandenberg dire que ce
dispositif de CDI seniors était
peut-être pas le mieux abouti donc moi
je proposerai volontiers de retirer cet
amendement et qu'on retravaille les
choses peut-être en vue de la loi
travail ou du prochain PLFSS mais encore
une fois prendre une mesure qui
coûterait 800 millions d'euros à la
branche famille sans qu'on ait de
garantie sur son efficacité vous avez
parlé de Paris mais je suis pas
totalement convaincu et pour répondre à
Monsieur Retailleau l'effet d'aubaine ça
serait si toutes les entreprises qui ont
actuellement un contrat avec un senior
de plus de 60 ans le transformer en CDI
seniors là ça serait 2 milliards 300
millions euros donc c'est pas ça dont je
parle quand je parle des 800 millions
d'euros le coût de 800 millions d'euros
c'est le coût pour les seniors qui
aujourd'hui rentrent dans un contrat
après 60 ans vous en avez 100 000 à peu
près chaque année qui sont recrutés on
imagine assez bien qu'un chef
d'entreprise qui recrute un seigneur qui
a plus de 60 ans il a le choix entre le
CDI classique sans allègement de
cotisation sur la branche famille et le
CDI senior où il a 5 points de
cotisation en moins sur
les cotisations familles il va plutôt
choisir le CDI seniors donc d'ores et
déjà pour les seniors qui sont
aujourd'hui recrutés sans qui ai besoin
dispositif supplémentaires ça coûte 800
millions d'euros donc peut-être qu'il y
en aura d'autres qui le seront à ce
moment-là en plus mais enfin il en
faudrait beaucoup pour que ça compense
les faits avant de conclure je veux
juste revenir sur la question des des
allègements et des exonérations de
cotisation ça a été abordé et j'ai
entendu parler notamment monsieur
kerouge de dualité dans le discours etc
il y a eu depuis 20 ans deux grandes
étapes d'allègement de cotisations pour
les entreprises
on perçoit aujourd'hui 21 milliards de
recettes en plus pour la sécurité
sociale parce que comme on a baissé les
cotisations il y a plus d'embauches un
million 500 mille de plus et donc on
perçoit aujourd'hui plus de recettes
puisqu'il y a plus de personnes qui
travaillent pour la sécurité sociale
donc oui alléger les cotisations a
permis d'élargir le nombre de
recrutement et donc d'avoir des recettes
supplémentaires pour la sécu donc pour
ces raisons-là c'est pour ça que je dis
j'ai pas de tabou sur la question des
baisses de cotisation merci Monsieur
Louise allons passer maintenant au vote
nous avons commencé par l'amendement
4741 madame Dubos ceux qui sont
favorables sur l'adoption manifeste en
levant la main
avis contraire
attention il n'est pas adopté
un sous amendement qui a été présenté
par
Monsieur Dufour madame guidez il est
maintenu
il est pas maintenu merci un amendement
présenté par Madame Lubin ceux qui sont
pour
avis contraire
attention je pense que nous avons le
même vote pour le suivant
il est et le suivant aussi il est ils ne
sont pas adoptés et nous allons passer
au vote par scrutin public demandez par
le groupe communiste républication
citoyen écologiste de l'amendement de la
commission du porteur numéro 21 12
rectifiés le scrutin est ouvert
le monde encore à voter
votant 344 exprimés 325 pour 202 contre
123 le Sénat a adopté
[Applaudissements]
nous allons examiner l'amendement 25,98
rectifié qui est présenté
par Madame de Seine merci
[Musique]
c'est amendement vise à encourager le
mentorat au travers d'un contrat ce
dispositif présente plusieurs intérêts
d'abord le maintien des seniors dans
l'emploi la transmission des
savoir-faire mais aussi l'incitation à
l'embauche des jeunes en les
accompagnant dans l'entreprise il y a
bien sûr une contrepartie à ce
dispositif et pour favoriser ce contrat
nous proposons une exonération des
charges sociales sur la branche famille
double intérêt et pour les entreprises
et pour les salariés puisque ça
représente un allège du coût du travail
pour l'entreprise et un gain de pouvoir
d'achat pour le salarié
alors monsieur le rapporteur David la
commission
quelque chose de tout à fait important
c'est la relation entre le jeûne et le
Seigneur
quelque part ça nous rappelle quelques
années qui avait proposé le contrat de
génération vous étiez bien interpellé
également mais les niveaux gel vous
voyez la cohérence avec le dispositif
sur l'emploi des seniors et on a bien vu
que ce dispositif n'avait pas forcément
fonctionné pourquoi parce qu'il y avait
pas une vision partagée par une pas une
ambition pour faire en sorte que la
société voit différemment les seniors à
l'intérieur de la dimension travail
c'est la raison pour laquelle ce type
d'emploi n'est pas suffisamment
incitatif et je le reconnais bien
volontiers aussi pour le CDI senior mais
c'est un outil supplémentaire et à force
d'avoir des outils de partager une
vision et bien je pense que tout le
monde sera utilisé ces outils pour en
revenir au mentorat effectivement là
aussi Chantal de Seine parle d'une
exonération
le contrat génération c'était une prime
je comprends sinon son amendement était
refusé c'est comme ça que l'amendement
sur les labels de Monsieur Babari qui
était tout à fait intéressant de
proposer un label comme la souligner la
rapporteur général a été effectivement
frappé d'y recevabilité donc Chantal de
scène très fine dans son analyse propose
effectivement une exonération mais il
est bien ce contrat de mentorat pourrait
être mis au goût du jour et d'ailleurs
les partenaires sociaux je ne sais plus
les lequel s'est reproposé d'essayer à
nouveau le contrat de génération et j'ai
dit pourquoi pas mais comme c'est une
prime sur le contrat de génération nous
ne pouvons pas l'inscrire dans le pdfsr
je partage le point de vue que c'est un
véhicule très réduit très réduit à la
fois pour faire une réforme des
retraites très réduit pour faire
également une réforme du travail c'est
la raison pour laquelle je souhaite
qu'on inscrive différents marqueurs pour
qu'au niveau de la réforme de travail
nous pouvions songer à tout ça donc la
Commission a trouvé intéressante et
demande la vie du gouvernement par
rapport à cela monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président de la
sénatrice je j'ai dit il y a quelques
instants que nous n'étions pas à ce
stade en tout cas totalement convaincu
la nécessité d'une belle forme de
contrat c'est ma mène à une demande de
retrait pour deux raisons que j'ajoute
et qui sont indépendantes de la nature
juridique la première raison c'est que
monsieur le rapporteur évoqué le contrat
de génération qui s'inscrivait dans les
mêmes principes qui n'avait pas
malheureusement pas marché pas marché
puisque nous étions sur quelques
centaines à peine de signatures par mois
sur la période la plus haute il n'y
avait pas d'effet incitatif pas d'effets
d'entraînement nous étions en moyenne à
680 signatures par mois sur la période
la plus importante la deuxième chose
c'est que nous considérons qu'en matière
de mentorat il y a certainement des
choses à regarder et à pousser qui
peuvent être travaillés différemment
d'abord avec des outils d'accompagnement
du mentorat nous avons un plan alors il
y a souvent des plans qu'on articule
autour d'un jeune et une solution sur
rapporteur proposé hier de dire un
seigneur une solution mais nous avons
aussi un plan sur le mentorat qui nous
permet de passer de 20 000 opérations de
mon temps apparent et de une jeune
mentorée à 200 000 et cette montée en
charge nous y arrivons sans qu'il y ait
une nécessité de mettre en place un
contrat particulier pour inciter au
mentorat il y a une deuxième raison qui
en fait qu'un peu plus loin dans le
texte nous aurons l'occasion d'examiner
ce que nous proposons en matière de
retraite progressive indépendamment des
quelques différences de d'ambition de
perception que nous avons avec la
commission de l'affaire sociale nous
voulons simplifier l'accès à la retraite
progressive et nous considérons que
faciliter l'accès à la retraite
progressive pour les employeurs c'est
une manière de diminuer le temps de
travail dont ils ont à leur charge et
donc de faciliter le redéploiement de
ces personnes sur du mentorat et de la
formation donc pour toutes ces raisons
c'est une demande de retrait avec la
perspic la perspective de la loi travail
qui nous permettra d'avancer mais je le
répète la montée en puissance du
mentorat nous y arrivons sans contrat
donc travaillons ensemble pour faire en
sorte que ce soit encore plus
effectivement
madame de chaîne
oui merci monsieur le Président au vu de
vous explications monsieur le ministre
je veux je vais retirer cet amendement
mais quand même ça favorise l'esprit
d'entreprise la transmission des
savoir-faire ça me semble
particulièrement important et je serai
attentive au moment d'une loi travail
pour que ce dispositif puisse être
amélioré et repris il est retiré un
amendement qui porte le numéro 42
qui le reprend
madame linman
parce que ce débat mérite d'être d'être
engagé on passe notre temps à nous
expliquer que la seule façon pour que
dans le travail dans l'entreprise ça va
nous ramener au retraite quand la seule
façon dans l'entreprise c'est de donner
des allègements de cotisation pour faire
ce skier toujours fait normalement dans
une entreprise c'est à dire que les plus
anciens les plus compétents contre Jacky
des compétences les transmettent aux
autres et c'est bien le débat s'il y a
une telle pression sur les salariés si
elle est salariés sont devenus de moins
en moins des acteurs d'une communauté
humaine qui est l'entreprise maintenant
tout le monde est sous pression sous
tension n'a pas le temps de faire vivre
cette transmission d'incompétence et on
croit qu'avec un allègement de
cotisation on va pouvoir régler ce
problème un ça va être des effets
d'aubaine de ça n'amélior pas le
mentorat qui doit être fondé sur un
certain volontarré volontariat et donc
pour ma part je suis totalement opposée
à cet amendement et puisque je l'ai
repris je le retire il est retiré bon
donc non on cesse de jouer avec ça et
nous poursuivons par l'examen du
l'amendement 4260 rectifié
monsieur Bocquet
excusez-nous monsieur le Président j'ai
vu qu'il y avait de la concurrence mais
je suis ravi
nous souhaitons par cet amendement
augmenter la pénalité financière des
entreprises qui ne respectent pas leur
obligation en matière d'égalité
professionnelle et notamment en matière
d'écart entre de rémunération entre les
hommes et les femmes chacun le sait ici
les inégalités que les femmes subissent
au travail se répercutent sur leurs
droits à la retraite et de statistiques
en rapport le constat est sans appel les
inégalités perdues durant la période
d'activité au point et se répercute je
viens de le dire sur la retraite au
point que le taux de pauvreté des femmes
retraités et supérieure à celui des
hommes 10,4 pour les femmes contre 8,5
pour les hommes et le problème c'est que
cet écart a tendance à continuer de se
creuser et non pas à se résorber 20% des
femmes sont contraintes d'attendre 67
ans pour partir en retraite en annulant
la décote pourtant toucher une pension à
taux plein et une des raisons de cette
situation c'est le recours banalisé
voire abusif autant partielle des
contrats qui concernent 4,6 millions de
personnes mais parmi ces 4,6 millions
3,7 millions de femmes et encore une
fois le mouvement tant à sa croître
puisque il sait contraire représente
aujourd'hui 19% des emplois contre 10 il
y a 30 ans donc nous voulons mettre fin
à ces inégalités qui se répercutent sur
la retraite
d'autant que ces contrats à temps
partiel
accroissent la pression sur chacune ou
chacun des salariés qu'il exerce puisque
bien souvent ça se traduit par faire
plus de travail en moins de temps qu'un
temps complet le père mettrait et donc
ça use davantage et donc c'est un double
effet négatif sur les retraites et ça
rend encore plus une inaccep véritable
recul de l'âge de départ de deux ans je
vous remercie je vais demander l'avis de
la commission et la vie du gouvernement
je signale que je suis de saisie d'une
demande de scrutin publique par le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen
oui merci effectivement
vous proposez
d'accroître les pénalités en ce qui
concerne cette index il n'était pas
publié ou s'il n'était pas évolutif dans
une période de trois ans mais vous
pouvez vous proposer à la fois
d'augmenter les pénalités et de réduire
le délai à un an de mise en conformité
en tout cas en l'absence d'action
significative pour faire en sorte
d'améliorer l'inégalité entre les hommes
et les femmes c'est notre
réflexion en ce qui concerne la
commission des affaires sociales à plus
haut penser que il existait déjà des
bases légales très précises en ce qui
homme femme contrairement à l'index
senior et en conséquence nous pensons
que ce n'est pas nécessaire appliquons
déjà le dispositif actuel impliquant les
pénalités si besoin et laissons trois
ans pour se mettre en conformité et là
si c'est pas mis en confirmité
effectivement peut être accroître les
pénalités merci merci monsieur le
ministre de vous être emparé de ce
slogan que nous avons laissé lancer à la
commission des affaires sociales à faire
un plan similaire c'était un jeune une
solution ça apportait ses fruits ça a
changé un petit peu la vision par
rapport aux emplois des jeunes c'est
significatifs mais écoutez on pourrait
essayer de décliner à l'Adour au moment
de la fin de carrière ce passage entre
la partie active et la sédentarité à
travers effectivement des dispositions
madame lillmann qui permettrait à
travers un CDI senior de faire du
tutorat à améliorer bien entendu mais
faire du tutorat et faire véritablement
un seigneur une solution si tout le
monde s'empare du dispositif et bien on
aura servi à quelque chose Monsieur le
Ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est une
demande de retrait ou à des fois on avis
défavorable pour des raisons assez
similaires assez exprimer par monsieur
le rapporteur nous considérons que
l'index égalité professionnelle donne
des premiers résultats il se trouve que
la toute dernière période d'observation
donne lieu à des résultats qui seront
publiés cette semaine puisqu'ils sont en
cours de consolidation des premiers
éléments qui nous arrivent la note
moyenne augmente et le taux de
déclaration qui est une déclaration
obligatoire sauf à subir des sanctions
augmente aussi et il y a un certain
nombre d'indicateurs qui vont dans le
bon sens l'année dernière au titre de
l'exercice de 2021 une grosse vingtaine
d'entreprises 25 ou 26 de mémoire avait
fait l'objet de sanctions financière
pour la première année nous estimons
plusieurs dizaines font l'objets de
sanctions financières cette année parce
que leur note est durablement inférieur
à ce qui est attendu mais globalement
les résultats sont plutôt bons sans
qu'il nous paraissent utile de renforcer
à ce stade les sanctions telles que
c'est prévu donc c'est retrait au
défavorable
merci
explication de votre madame meunier
la procédure
moi je
la Signat brûlant d'exposer cet
amendement et je rappelle que dans la
catégorie des seniors il y a des femmes
et les femmes seniorent en emploi sont
davantage à temps partiel 32% pour les
femmes contre 11% pour les hommes et
elles sont en situation de sous-emploi
cette virgule 8% contre 4,3% pour les
hommes et quand elles sont au chômage la
durée moyenne du chômage des femmes est
de 50 de 50 à 59 ans et de 53 jours
supérieurs à celles des hommes du même
âge les montants qu'elle perçoivent par
l'assurance chômage sont
significativement plus faibles de 33%
environ
à partir de 60 ans cet écart atteint 44%
donc c'est 950 net 950 euros net par
mois pour les femmes et 1650 euros pour
les hommes c'est le reflet des
inégalités de salaires et des inégalités
de carrière donc si nos collègues les
républicains voulaient effectivement
avoir un effet sur l'emploi des seniors
il faut mes chers collègues vous
intéresser aussi aux inégalités
inscrites à l'intérieur même de ce qu'on
appelle les salariés seniors la
présidente Laurence Rossignol
merci
d'abord nous voterons cet amendement
parce qu'effectivement il permet de
renforcer les outils mis en place et
pour autant je rappelle ce que j'ai dit
hier les outils mis en place sont
insuffisants et Monsieur le Ministre
effectivement on pouvait dire que la
note augmente que les entreprises sont
de plus en plus nombreuses à satisfaire
à l'obligation de publication mais ce
que vous ne dites pas c'est les
critiques qui émanent d'institutions
publiques de recherche sur la manière
dont est faite cette note et en
particulier sur ces quatre ces quatre
critères et ce que l'on sait c'est que
une grande partie de ce qu'ils font les
inégalités salariales entre les hommes
et les femmes sont invisibilisés par le
système de notation qui était retenu
dans l'index puisque ce que vous avez ce
qui a été retenu c'est des quarts de
rémunération les quarts de répartition
des promotions des cartes de répartition
des augmentations et la part des
salariés augmentés après un une
maternité mais ce que ça ne dit pas pour
autant ce qui reste invisible c'est la
sur-reprétation des femmes dans les
emplois temps partiel et dans les
professions à bas salaire parce que il y
a quand même une donnée qui est
constante c'est que les professions les
plus féminisées sont les professions les
plus mal rémunérés alors il y a mille et
une explications de ça en particulier
que ce sont les métiers du soin et qu'on
a considéré pendant des décennies que
c'était une activité bénévole des femmes
et que quand elles ont commencé à la
faire à l'extérieur du foyer et dans une
activité rémunérée on a prolongé cette
idée du bénévolat des femmes à l'égard
de des métiers du soin donc cet
amendement il permet d'ouvrir une porte
ils ne les ouvre pas toutes mais c'est
déjà une avancée de me la vautrons
je suis bloqué puis madame
oui merci monsieur le Président la
majorité des inégalités dont sont
victimes les femmes sur le plan de la
retraite sont dues à des manquements
intervenus durant toute la carrière
avant la retraite dès lors nous mettre
en place des moyens contraignants afin
d'encourager les bonnes pratiques et de
compenser les différences de parcours
entre les femmes et les hommes et nous
pensons que votre réforme est un rebours
de cet objectif même si l'étude d'impact
affirme que une pension moyenne des
femmes va augmenter plus vite que celle
des hommes vu qu'elle travailleront plus
longtemps et cotiseront donc plus
notamment aux caisses complémentaires il
n'en demeure pas moins que l'écart entre
femmes et hommes de l'ordre de 40% en
termes de pension n'est pas et ne sera
pas à l'évidence rattrapée en repoussant
l'âge de la retraite elle est toujours
moins atteignable pour les femmes
notamment par l'absence de mise en place
par les employeurs de l'égalité
salariale et professionnelle entre les
femmes et les hommes au travail il nous
faut rendre l'égalité salariale et
professionnelle effective ce serait
ainsi mettre fin à une injustice
flagrante et véritablement le ce qu'on
appelle le name shame nommé et blâmer
est loin de d'avoir l'efficacité requise
dans ce genre de situation merci
que si je partage le constat qui a été
fait sur les bancs jusqu'à l'instant je
partage pas la position sur la
demandement oui aujourd'hui il y a des
inégalités salariales oui il y a des
inégalités de carrière oui nous avons
tenté de diminuer ces inégalités à
travers différents textes et notamment
la proposition de loi que nous qui est
devenue loi sur l'égalité économique et
professionnelle donc il y a des outils
mais on ne va pas réussir à finalement
corriger toutes ces inégalités dont font
l'objet des femmes à travers un projet
de loi sur les retraites c'est en
réalité on utilise un projet de loi sur
les retraites pour corriger des
carrières or les carrières et bien c'est
évidemment une loi travail c'est
évidemment des propositions à faire sur
sur la réglementation sur
l'accompagnement des femmes et des
parcours de femmes donc oui pour le
constat non pour le vote sur
l'amendement je vous remercie
je pense merci monsieur le Président je
pense précisément qu'une réforme des
retraites juste devrait se donner pour
priorité de corriger les inégalités en
matière de différence quand même
extrêmement important de retraite entre
les hommes et les femmes et je le redis
c'est différent elle s'explique par les
carrières et les emplois qui sont
occupés par les uns et par les autres
prenons les aesh et je sais madame la
présente de la délégation que vous
connaissez bien le sujet ce sont ah je
crois 90% des femmes avec des contrats
qui sont souvent de moins de 24 heures
semaine avec des salaires qui
n'atteignent même pas les 900 euros si
je prends des caissières de supermarché
elles ont elles aussi souvent des
contrats à temps extrêmement partiels si
on prend les salariés qui travaillent
dans tout le secteur de l'entretien avec
des amplitudes horaires phénoménales
et bien je pense qu'il faut que nous
soyons plus volontariste et que les
outils que nous développons soient
beaucoup plus ferme pour corriger cela
parce que vous savez il y a de multiples
choses qui mettent les gens dans la rue
en ce moment et certains ont nous ont
fait l'honneur de croire que nous en
étions quasiment les uniques
responsables mais une des premières
choses qui a mis des gens dans la rue
est particulièrement des femmes c'est la
non-volont volonté de corriger ces
inégalités il y a énormément de femmes
dans les cortèges et je pense que chacun
serait bien intentionné de les écouter
il n'y a pas de recette miracle et
effectivement les dispositifs vont
mettre du temps à faire leur effet mais
si on se dit bon bah les choses avancent
après tout ça fera son effet le moment
viendra ou enfin l'égalité sera là je
crois qu'on est vraiment en dessous de
la réalité de l'aspiration des femmes
oui merci monsieur le Président moi il y
a quelque chose qui m'étonne toujours y
compris dans cette hémicycle c'est quand
des collègues ou des ministres au bord
du gouvernement nous disent mais ça
commence à faire effet on est en 2023 il
y a toujours pas d'égalité
professionnelle malgré les nombreuses
lois qui ont été votées il y a pas
d'amélioration réelle des conditions de
travail et pas non plus des conditions
de retraite et messieurs les ministres
avec votre réforme vous allez encore
aggraver les choses vous allez aggraver
les choses et à tel point d'ailleurs que
toutes les associations féministes ou
les syndicats sont vend debout sur cette
réforme et particulièrement sur le sort
qui est réservé aux femmes quand on ne
prend pas en compte le fait que ce sont
elles et ça a été dit par mes collègues
qui ont des carrières hachées qui ont
une pénibilité dans de nombreux métiers
maximum on parle effectivement des des
travailleuses et des travailleurs
première de corvées lors notamment de la
covid on les a applaudis au gouvernement
aussi vous les avez applaudis mais ça a
été quoi après les conséquences qui ont
été tirées pour améliorer les choses
aucune et quand vous osez prendre comme
référence l'index sur l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes pour essayer
hier de nous faire passer la pilule sur
l'index des seniors c'est quand même de
l'enfumage pourquoi c'est de l'enfumage
parce que l'index pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes est totalement
insuffisant et vous ne nous écoutez pas
vous ne nous entendez pas vous refusez
de nous entendre ici dans l'hémicycle
mais aussi dans la rue et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs demain la mobilisation va
être extrêmement forte et c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour tout le monde c'est
une bonne nouvelle parce que ça va
peut-être faire bouger les choses mais
là encore vous préférez dialoguer entre
vous plutôt que d'entendre la
représentation parlementaire
pour régler le problème mais madame
billon oui c'est un problème de recettes
parce que vous vous nous expliquez qu'on
est obligé de travailler jusqu'à 60
avantages égal à 64 parce que
globalement on a un trou dans la honoré
un déficit mais il aurait pas de
difficile si le niveau des salaires
étaient meilleurs si le niveau des
salaires des femmes étaient égales à
celui des hommes il y aurait pas de
difficile si si vous vous payez
correctement les métiers d'ailleurs dans
la simulation qui a été faite sur les
sur les retraites il a été prévu que
dans la fonction publique ni embauche et
gel du point d'indice or les femmes les
infirmières les professeurs le nombre
important de femmes dans les
collectivités locales vous n'allez pas
augmenter leur salaire vous n'allez pas
revaloriser leur métier et vous allez en
creuser les caisses de retraite et nous
faire travailler ou de la 64 ans
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues on
sait que la retraite c'est le refrain de
la vie à la fois de des inégalités de la
vie mais aussi peut-être des promesses
ou en tout cas de ce qui n'a pas pu être
tenu dans une vie et je trouve que ce
débat que nous avons aujourd'hui
en tout cas par l'amendement que je
salue de Madame Brulin et est
intéressant parce que finalement à
celles et ceux qui disent mais ne vous
inquiétez pas ça avance finalement on va
réussir aujourd'hui en 2023 c'était car
de 40% est absolument énorme
on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire et on le
sait bien alors pourquoi refuser des
dispositifs qui vont permettre de
contraindre un peu plus ou en tout cas
de faire pousser un peu plus ces
inégalités je trouve que aujourd'hui
quand on parle des femmes et Madame
Brulin l'a dit on sait que le taux de
pauvreté est plus élevé 10,4% pour les
femmes quand il n'est que de 8,5% pour
les hommes et un dernier chiffre qui est
imparable c'est que l'écart entre le
taux de pauvreté moyens des femmes et
des hommes retraités a tendance oui mes
chers collègues à se creuser depuis 2012
puisque aujourd'hui nous sommes à 1,9
points en 2019 alors qu'il n'était que
de 0,6 points en 2012 donc vraiment je
trouve que c'est important et je
vauterai cet amendement bien nous allons
procéder
au scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter le
scrutin avec l'eau
résultat moteur 344 exprimé 332 pour 91
contre 241 de Sénat n'a pas adopté et
nous passons
à l'amendement
3219 madame poncemont je le présente il
y a sous forme d'abondement qui vont
faire l'objet d'une discussion commune
merci monsieur le président Halloween il
s'agit par cet amendement
d'obliger les entreprises à publier des
indicateurs relatifs à la continuité des
carrières si vous voulez un poursuite
des parcours professionnels sans rupture
en effet les personnes ayant des
carrières hachées sont pénalisés
notamment lors de leur départ à la
retraite et la présente loi ici agrave
ce phénomène par l'accélération de la
durée requise pour avoir un temps plein
et oui monsieur le rapporteur ce qui est
d'une brutalité inédite c'est bien la
synergie des deux paramètres c'est à
dire des mesures d'âge et là c'est
toujours la droite qui les a voté et
aussi effectivement de la durée requise
donc qui appartient à certes à Madame
Touraine mais l'accélération c'est vous
selon
l'adresse je dirais pour mieux
comprendre d'ailleurs cela c'est qu'il y
a une personne qui est commune
à ces deux assez de c'est quand même
monsieur Macron qui était déjà dans
l'équipe qu'il avait très bien inspiré
selon selon l'adresse 32% des retraités
de la génération 50 ont une carrière
incomplète alors il est normal que les
personnes ayant des carrières hachées
perçoivent des retraites plus faibles
enfin c'est pas que c'est normal c'est
que c'est c'est logique en 2016 les
carrières incomplètes représentent 60%
des personnes qui bénéficient d'un
minimum de pension du régime général
les carrières hachées obligent de
nombreuses femmes à liquider tardivement
leurs droits à la retraite et les oblige
à poursuivre jusqu'à 67 ans elles sont
20% contre 10% des hommes âge de la fin
de l'application de la décote et cela ne
les préserve pas pour autant d'une
retraite faible c'est simplement la
double peine qui s'arrête à 67 ans
l'amendement 25 23 monsieur le Président
gauta oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président cet amendement instaure dans
toutes les entreprises depuis 300
salariés des indicateurs de continuité
de carrière ces indicateurs et leurs
méthodes de calcul sont définies par
décret peuvent être complétés par
convention ou par accord de branche
l'amendement prévoit enfin des pénalités
financières pour les entreprises qui ne
respecteraient pas ces obligations ces
indicateurs en plus plusieurs objectifs
le premier renforcer la prise de
conscience des entreprises sur le fléau
que représente les carrières hachées
subies et les inciter donc à faire des
efforts assurer la transparence des
pratiques de chaque entreprise auprès
des partenaires sociaux des
administrations d’état et du public
octroyer au pouvoir public les données
précieuses leur permettant d'agir en
conséquence les carrières hachées
touchent majoritairement des femmes
exerçant dans des métiers pénibles les
temps partiels sont souvent imposées aux
femmes dans des métiers précaires et le
texte ne s'attaque absolument pas à ce
phénomène or notre système de retraite
est pensé sur le modèle des carrières
des hommes le retraite son calcul et
deux facteurs salaires et durée de
Carrière Or les femmes ont des carrières
plus courtes ou des salaires plus
faibles que c'est des hommes les
différentes études le montrent les
femmes se retirent souvent de l'emploi
pour prendre en charge les enfants ou
pour prendre soin d'un parent malade ou
dépendant une femme sur deux réduit ou
arrête complètement son activité
professionnelle à l'arrivée d'un enfant
c'est le cas d'un homme sur neuf
résultat les femmes entre 25 et 54 ans
ont un taux d'activité de 8 points
inférieurs à celui des hommes 84% contre
92%. cumuler aux inégalités salaires la
conséquence des carrières hachées et
triple des pensions plus faibles le
montant des pensions de droit direct est
inférieurs de 40% à celui versé aux
hommes même après le versement de la
pension réversion les femmes perçoivent
une pension inférieure de 28% à celle
des hommes par ailleurs 37% des femmes
de retraite touchent moins de 1000 euros
de pension brutes un taux plein
difficilement atteint seul 60% des
femmes partent à la retraite à taux
plein contre 68% des hommes des départs
plus tardifs à la retraite en moyenne 6
mois plus tard
merci l'amendement suivant qui le
présente Madame Monsieur Breuillet
non je sens que vous êtes en concurrence
3500 3
parce que
beaucoup de choses que je voulais dire
ont été dites donc je vais essayer de
dire ce qui n'a pas été dit alors
effectivement c'est ce sont des
amendements relatifs à l'impact des
carrières hachées qui touche ça a été
dit ça par contre majoritairement les
femmes et je voudrais peut-être que
c'est par construction sociale et non de
façon innée mais pas construction
sociale les femmes effectivement sont
renvoyées au métier du prendre soin les
femmes se retirent souvent de l'emploi
pour prendre en charge les enfants ou
pour prendre en charge un parent malade
ou dépendant les aidants les fameuses
aidants qui vont faire l'objet de
d'un amendement effectivement sont
essentiellement des femmes
et une femme sur deux réduit arrête
complètement son activité
professionnelle ou arrête
professionnelle à l'arrivée d'un enfant
c'est le cas d'un homme seulement sur
neuf et ils en profite pour dire qu'il
faudra accompagner une évolution sociale
quand même un peu trop lente on va pas
attendre trois siècles quand même que
pour que les femmes soient moins comme
ça assignés aux tâches du prendre soin
donc il faudra accompagner cette
évolution sociétale avec d'autres
réformes et nous vous proposerons
notamment plus tard un changement
législatif sur le congé paternel
post-natal qui soit allongé parce que
c'est peut-être à ce moment là que les
comportements y compris tout au long de
la vie pour s'occuper après de quelqu'un
de malade ou de quelqu'un d'une personne
âgée en perte d'autonomie si dès le
départ dès le la naissance le congé
paternel post natal j'ai fini alors
voilà j'ai dit des choses différentes je
vous remercie
monsieur Breuillet
et si monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les ministres
collègues cet amendement déposé par mon
collègue dessus n'est pas concurrent il
a effectivement totalement
complémentaire et cohérent avec ceux qui
viennent défendus pour les femmes c'est
effectivement la triple peine inégalité
salariale inégalité des pensions
inégalités du temps de travail et les
chiffres en témoignent ils sont
dramatiques à l'heure actuelle une femme
sur cinq est contrainte de travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein contre un homme
sur dix les carrières des femmes sont
généralement hachées et c'est la raison
de cet amendement d'appel parce qu'elles
sont socialisées au travail du Caire
lorsqu’un de leurs parents devient
malade ou dépendant lorsqu'elles ont un
enfant les femmes sont celles qui en
général quittent leur emploi et
travaillent à temps partiel et c'est
inégalité ne doit pas perdurer dans le
temps force est de constater que la
réforme n'améliore pas cette situation
des femmes peut-être d'ailleurs parce
que encore une fois le gouvernement
choisi un véhicule injuste et
inapproprié un petit véhicule législatif
d'une loi de finance rectificative pour
parler d'un énorme problème qui est
celui du travail et de la retraite mais
on retombe toujours sur les visions
alors mon collègue évoquait la situation
d'une personne je donne pas son nom 55
ans né en 68 elle a passé 8 ans sans
travailler pour élever ses quatre
enfants et a commencé à travailler à 20
ans avant la réforme ces 8 années sans
travailler étaient compensés par les 8
trimestres données par enfant pour les
enfants et par le congé parental elle
pouvait donc partir à 62 ans après la
réforme elle devra attendre 64 ans pour
partir à la retraite et elle perd la
surcote de 7 et demi pour cent dont elle
aurait bénéficié en travaillant jusqu'à
64 ans autre problème les temps partiels
souvent imposés dans les métiers
précaires ne sont pas du tout pris en
compte dans ce texte pour toute cette
saison nous demandons au gouvernement de
revoir sa copie
madame ponce présente l'amendement 3500
oui alors cet amendement vise à
instaurer un indicateur relatif à la
continuité des carrières afin de prendre
toute la mesure de l'impact des
carrières hachées en France sur la
retraite
c'est pourquoi les entreprises de plus
de 300 salariés seraient contrainte de
publier l'index et celles qui
méconnaissent l'obligation de
publication avec d'ailleurs les
indicateurs que vous n'avez pas retenu
hier mais qui permettrait effectivement
d'être plus pertinent que ceux dont a
priori on entend parler et bien ceux qui
ne méconnent mettrai les entreprises
l'obligation de publication devrait
recevoir appliquer par l'autorité
administrative une pénalité
je reviens quand même sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure sur les deux
paramètres qu'on fait bouger en même
temps ce qu'on met en synergie on l'a
dit la durée requise c'est vrai en
général la durée requise de cotisation
touche de façon différentielle tout le
monde bien sûr mais et plus et en
général très impactante pour les femmes
à cause justement de ces carrières
hachées les mesures d'allongement de
l'âge d'ouverture du droit à la retraite
touche en général tout le monde mais
plus particulièrement les catégories
socio-professionnelles ouvriers employés
qualifié ou non qualifiés
d'ailleurs est-ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que la synergie et bien
effectivement c'est les ouvrières les
employés femmes dans les métiers de
service qui elle en tant que femme si
vous voulez cette synergie vraiment
impact plus particulièrement nous en
reparlerons
le 8 mars pour dire que cette réforme
pour voilà pour dire que c'est très
réforme est une réforme quand le monde
du travail mais aussi contre les femmes
bien
dans le passé a demandé l'avis du de la
Commission à la vie du gouvernement je
voulais signaler que je suis saisi de
deux demandes de scrutin public sur les
deux premiers amendements
oui merci monsieur le président
je suis surpris de voir comme vous
devenez des adeptes de l'intex Senior et
des index en général
voyez-vous moi j'avais dit que j'étais
pas fan des index je vous l'ai dit dès
le départ bon à la rigueur l'index
Seigneur mais j'irai pas plus loin dans
dans les index voyez-vous et surtout
pour parler des carrières hachées je
pense que c'est pas un index qu'il faut
c'est les valoriser vous voyez je serai
plutôt sur le label pour les carrières
hachées plutôt que sur les index mais ça
permet de rappeler un certain nombre de
choses parce que vous avez dénoncé à
juste titre mais ça a été dénoncé aussi
sur les bancs de la droite les
inégalités de carrière
effectivement c'est au cours de la
carrière professionnelle qu'il y a de
nombreux d'inégalités et elle se
traduisent après au moment de la
retraite c'est incontournable je vous
rappelle à ce propos là que c'est un
système par point les corrige pas
elles sont peut-être plus corrigées un
système paranuité que par un système par
point preuve en est c'est que les
agriculteurs nous ont demandé qu'on
calcule leur pension qui était sur un
système à points par des annuités ce qui
montre bien que les réformes de retraite
quelle qu'elle soit il y a tellement
d'inégalités sur le plan salarial sur le
plan des retraites qui se retraduisent
certaines sont gommés je vous rappelle
quand même que les montants de retraite
les différences de montants entre les
plus aisées et les plus pauvres sont
atténués par rapport aux différences de
salaires donc il y a un effet
redistributif à l'intérieur de notre
système paraît partition qui est
contributive qui gomme certaines
inégalités mais par contre
les différences qu'il est entre régime
peut en accentuer d'autres donc ça nous
a pas échappé qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose pour les carrières hachées
notamment pour les maires de famille
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons un dispositif de surcote à
l'article 8 mes chers collègues
il est important il est important vous
qui êtes attaché à ces inégalités
notamment pour les niveaux de pension
notamment pour la prise en compte des
trimestres des mers de famille il est
important que nous puissions aller
jusque l'article 8 de faire en sorte que
quelque part dans nos débats on arrive à
s'entendre mais gagner un peu de temps
quand même parce que nos consignes rien
ont besoin qu'on amène
un peu plus de justice sociale au niveau
de cette réforme notamment avec les
maires de famille et ça peut être une
discussion qui peut les intéresser à ce
niveau là c'est la raison également pour
laquelle
nous avons pensé à travers ce dispositif
de prendre en compte les trimestres de
majoration qui ne seront pas
suffisamment brouillés en compte et je
réponds à Monsieur brolier parce que
dans l'exemple qui nous donne monsieur
Broly
si j'ai bien compris vous parlez d'une
mère de famille de trois enfants ce qui
veut dire cette mère de famille elle a
trois fois huit trimestres de majoration
en ce qui concerne la prise en compte de
ces maternités dans le système privé par
contre elle n'aura que deux trimestres
selon la date 2 à 4 trimestres puisque
il y a une modification dans le secteur
public là aussi c'est une inégalité
c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
verrez qu'à l'article 8 quand on parle
de la prise en compte des maires de
famille avec des majorations on met à
une majoration voyez-vous on n'a pas mis
un nombre de majorations parce que
justement on entretenait cette
différence entre le public et le privé
qui méritera d'être discuté c'est
reporté à des travaux du corps compter
sur modique Lubin et moi-même pour faire
en sorte que et Jean-Marie redberg qui
fait partie du corps pour faire en sorte
qu'on soit attentif à trouver des
solutions parce que nous considérons que
ces particulièrement inégalitaire et
actuellement il y a déjà dans le système
de calculs de pension 20% de ces
majorations qui ne sont pas prises en
compte ces maires de famille qui pensent
que leur majoration veulent attribuer
des points supplémentaires à la fois
pour le calcul de la durée leur
permettant derrière d'éviter parfois un
phénomène de décote ne sont pas pris en
compte à hauteur de 20% dans
l'augmentation de la durée d'âge ça
c'est un effet connexe on n'y peut rien
c'est 30% des majorations qui ne seront
pas pris c'est la raison pour laquelle
ça nous a interpellé que nous proposons
ce dispositif de surcote donc pour
conclure monsieur le Président on peut
pas gommer toutes les inégalités et nous
aurons encore des propositions à faire
dans ce domaine là merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre non très
rapidement monsieur le Président la
question des carrières hachées c'est
évidemment un vrai sujet et c'est vrai
que les carrières hachées se révèlent
encore plus au moment de la retraite
avec des pensions qui sont moins
importantes je suis pas convaincu que
l'outil index soit le mieux adapté pour
répondre à la question des carrières
hachées d'abord parce que si le salarié
est dans l'entreprise c'est bien que
l'entreprise en question permet de
réduire le côté haché de la carrière
puisqu'elle a recruté le salarié et donc
je vois pas je trouve ça un peu bizarre
d'aller pointer du doigt à l'entreprise
qui précisément lui permet aux salariés
d'être dans l'entreprise si c'est sur la
question des contrats courts madame
lilleman je vous entendais m'interpeller
pour moi la question des contrats courts
elle est traitée en grande partie par le
bonus malus qu'on a mis en place sur les
cotisations des entreprises liées au
recours au contrats courts ça me semble
beaucoup plus efficace cette mesure là
que l'index donc pour ces raisons
défavorables merci
nous allons passer au vote explication
de vote madame Meunier est inscrite
merci monsieur le Président moi je
voterais les amendements proposés par le
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
ça a été dit triple Pen pour les femmes
et notamment donc les carrières hachées
alors bien sûr l'index c'est pas l'alpha
et l'oméga mais c'est un moyen que l'on
peut avec des critères bien resserrés se
servir pour contraindre ceci dit je sais
que c'est pas la panacée et je vais vous
donner un exemple de ce qui existe dans
l'index et Gap pro et Gap pro donne la
note donc égalité professionnelle entre
les femmes et les hommes donne la note
de 92 sur 100 un groupe hôtelier là on
peut dire bravo quand on y regarde de
près l'indicateur 1 celui qui mesure
l'écart de rémunération entre les femmes
et les hommes par tranche d'âge et
catégories socioprofessionnelle ABC
passant de 38 40 à 33 sur 40 donc
l'écart a dû augmenter en défaveur des
femmes mais cette baisse est compensée
par une autre dimension qu'on trouve à
l'indec à l'indicateur 5 et qui lui
équilibre entre le nombre de femmes et
le nombre d'hommes dans les 10 plus
hautes
catégories de rémunération et là donc on
peut penser que cette entreprise a
embauché plus de femmes donc vous voyez
comment le diable se niche dans les
détails parce que plus de femmes mais
moins rémunéré et au total une bonne
note donc on peut faire dire ce que l'on
veut aux index et c'est pour ça qu'on
est très méfiant sur les indexes seniors
en rapprochant et en resserrant les
critères on peut peut-être avoir plus de
garanties
je pense que les index c'est vraiment
pas la la panacée néanmoins j'observe
qu'on veut bien mettre des index sur
certains sujets et pas sur d'autres et
de ce point de vue la précarité du
salariat les carrières hachées c'est
quand même une des grandes crises du
monde du travail aujourd'hui donc comme
Madame chaque fois chers collègues je me
trompe de votre nom c'est pas si je dois
faire un blocage pensez
le fait cette proposition avec ses
collègues c'est une bonne proposition
parce qu'elle équilibre le regard qu'on
doit avoir sur la situation mais
monsieur le ministre
vous ne faites aucun vous n'avez pas du
tout l'intention de faire des progrès
pour réduire les carrières hachées
puisque en tout cas pour les femmes
puisque dans les simulations du corps
que vous avez et les données que vous
avez données on maintient le taux
d'activité des femmes en 2030 excusée tu
peux à l'actuel taux d'activités des
femmes or le taux d'activité des femmes
il est lié aussi à la précarité des
emplois des femmes pas simplement
d'avoir un emploi c'est de équivalent en
place je peux dire donc vous n'avez
aucune attention politique de faire
reculer la précarité dans pour les
métiers féminins puisque vous maintenez
le taux d'activité des femmes enfin
monsieur le rapporteur
j'adore votre proposition de dire on va
pas faire des Indes contraignants on va
faire des labels alors moi j'imagine
bien le groupe Airbus
ayant face à lui plusieurs
sous-traitants pour telle ou tel
activité dire ah ben non finalement
celui-là il est un petit peu plus cher
ou moins cher mais il a quand même un
label Qualité
emploi du seniors donc finalement je
vais prendre le label donc franchement
les labels n'ont pas cette efficacité
monsieur Lecomte
remercie monsieur le Président Monsieur
Miss mes chers collègues je soutiendrai
bien entendu c'est c'est ces amendements
même s'ils ne constitue pas en eux-mêmes
des solutions aux difficultés indiquées
concernant les inégalités salariales en
particulier femme homme et des carrières
hachées toutefois si on veut avancer sur
le plan des résolutions c'est mieux de
les connaître de les chiffrer et de bien
les préciser donc ça son utilité je
regrette aussi que finalement dans cette
réforme même si le débat que nous avons
sur ces points montre combien il est
important de pouvoir améliorer ces
dispositions à la fois pour permettre
des des meilleurs retraites mais aussi
pour mieux favoriser les carrières
longues et les carrières qui permettent
finalement de cotiser à la retraite mais
je voudrais aussi en tant que sénateur
représentant les Français établiors de
France parler des carrières H&M
internationales
des membres d'un couple qui suivent leur
conjoint et qui se trouve en situation
d'avoir interrompu leur carrière des
réflexions sur ce sujet existe de la
même manière que dans plusieurs pays
européens vous avez la possibilité soit
pendant votre carrière
soit au moment de la liquidation de
votre retraite de partager ou de
transmettre à votre conjoint des
annuités ou des trimestres cotisés et il
me semble qu'une réflexion dans ce
domaine mais hériterait aussi d'être
pris en compte bien entendu ça ne serait
pas un avantage pour la les cotisations
à l'assurance vieillesse par contre pour
les personnes concernées ça permettrait
de limiter un certain nombre de
personnes qui aujourd'hui se trouvent
avec des guerrières hachées des
handicaps au moment de liquidation de
retraite parce qu'ils ont favorisé la
carrière de leur conjoint et je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui mériterait
d'être fait en tout état que sur tous
ces sujets on voit bien que c'est pas à
la va-vite que nous pouvons résoudre ces
problèmes mais bien dans un vrai projet
de loi de réforme des retraites qui qui
mettrait dans la loi des accords entre
partenaires sociaux
le résidentiel collègue monsieur le
ministre
je voudrais ces amendements mais
j'aimerais attirer l'attention de mes
collègues sur la situation des Outre-mer
on fait un texte et qui aura des
conséquences catastrophiques dans les
outre-mer par exemple on vient de
prendre
contrat de fin de carrière pour les
entreprises de plus de 300 salariés
95% des entreprises dans tous les
outre-mer n'ont pas 300 salariés ils ont
moins de 50 ça veut dire que ça va pas
s'appliquer là-bas l'index égalité et
bien les dettes là-bas ne les publie pas
en tout cas je ne les connais pas
l'inégalité
salariale et professionnelle entre
hommes et femmes et puisqu'il s'agit de
car hier haché j'ai ici des chiffres
effrayants
quand on prend le chômage entre 15 et 29
ans 33% des jeunes ne sont pas en
activité et quand on prend les
les
534 ans quand en métropole c'est 70% des
gens qui sont en taux d'activité et bien
là-bas c'est
55%. c'est effrayant ça ne va les
conséquences là-bas seront
dramatiques tout ce qui est pris là y
compris sur les carrières le royaume de
la précarité de la pauvreté et des
carrières HC dans les outre-mer rien
n'est pris aucune étude préalable n'a
été faite aucune étude d'impact et oui
loi de financement on peut s'en passer
notre synthèse non communiquée on ne
sait rien on vote à l'aveugle et j'avoue
que j'aimerais que les outre-mer
entendent ça on a abîmé depuis 2017 les
outre-mer tout ce qu'ils avaient y
compris heureusement la commission des
affaires sociales vient de à rectifier
dans ces travaux et bien le seuil de
Rico et bien qui était qui est à 100000
euros et bien va généraliser dans le
besoin merci la commission des affaires
sociales
mais l'impossible
monsieur le Président enfin j'aimerais
ne pas quand même régulièrement de voir
rappeler qu'on n'était pas contre
l'index mais qu'on était contre la place
de cet index dans cette loi et que
puisque vous avez maintenu la Dex il est
normal qu'on en discute et qu'on essaie
de l'enrichir et justement
sur y compris sur la continuité des
carrières sur des carrières sans rupture
je pense qu'il y a des indicateurs alors
il faut aller travailler on les a pas
proposés là bien sûr mais des
indicateurs qui effectivement peuvent
avoir un impact sur les carrières
hachées et notamment tout comme pour
l'égalité homme-femme il faudra des
choses sur le temps partiel par exemple
il faudra aussi peut-être mettre les
congés parentaux partiels ce qui sont
totales et ce qui sont partiels parce
que effectivement ça peut montrer
comment on peut aménager ou pas le temps
de travail pour pas obliger
un des parents à savoir des femmes si
arrêter
leur carrière faute de crèche ou faute
d'une organisation du travail qui en
tienne compte et qui leur permettent
parce qu'il faut aussi adapter les
postes et les organisations du travail
aux hommes et non le contraire il n'y a
pas que on adapte pas l'homme à des
mauvaises organisations de travail
toxique ou à des postes de travail qui
alors effectivement il faudra modifier
enfin travailler ces
indicateurs parce que celui de des
femmes hommes s'il est aussi inefficace
c'est parce que on ne le fait pas
évoluer qu'on ne l'enrichit pas qu'on se
contente simplement de dire une majorité
avec tous les biais dont on a parlé ont
une bonne note alors tout va bien alors
qu'il y a une augmentation lorsque elle
l'a dit 10 pour les femmes sans pour les
hommes c'est bon vous avez vous avez une
bonne note et puis on parle bien sûr des
promotions pour le plafond de verre de
verre éviter de plafond de verre mais il
faudrait mesurer et je termine le
plafond collant c'est à dire les femmes
qui à l'embauche ont déjà un salaire
différent de celui des hommes madame
billot
merci monsieur le Président alors oui
pour lutter contre les inégalités
salariales madame et monsieur le
rapporteur madame président de la
commission oui pour lutter contre les
inégalités à la retraite mais non ce
texte ne nous permettra pas de réduire
toutes ces années égalités alors moi je
suis vraiment
attaché à l'égalité salariale mais on
peut peut-être se demander aussi
pourquoi à la veille puisqu'il a été
fait mention du 8 mars pourquoi nous
n'avons pas plus de femmes il y avait
beaucoup de femmes dans le numérique
lorsque le numérique n'était pas à ce
stade important sur le marché du travail
des représentait pas tant d'emploi
aujourd'hui il y a quasiment plus de
femmes dans le numérique désormais donc
on peut se demander pourquoi on n'agit
pas plus au niveau de l'orientation de
la formation nous avons rendu un rapport
femme et ruralité avec la délégation au
droit des femmes où on voyait
véritablement les inégalités
d'orientation et de formation dans les
territoires donc moi ce que je voudrais
aussi vous dire c'est que on a entendu à
l'instant
défendre ou critiquer l'index alors faut
choisir soit l'index c'est un bon outil
soit c'est un mauvais outil auquel cas
on va pas demander à l'étendre à plus
d'entreprises donc déjà là je trouve
qu'il y a quelque chose qui colle pas et
je partage l'intervention qui a eu le
monsieur le rapporteur tout à l'heure
mais je voudrais quand même lui dire
attention au label parce que c'est vrai
que lorsqu'il y a pas de contrainte
l'égalité elle ne progresse pas ou très
peu et comme le disait notre collègue
Laurence Cohen tout à l'heure s'il n'y
avait pas eu des contraintes les femmes
dans la retraite en tentation politique
par exemple dans les seuils de moins de
1000 habitants pour l'égalité et ben on
ne serait peut-être pas mesdames aussi
nombreuses aujourd'hui dans l'hémicycle
donc attention à ces bonnes idées mais
véritablement oui pour la surcotte oui
pour travailler peut-être l'index
différemment parce que l'index est un
outil assez récent et donc on devra
peut-être l'améliorer pour qu'il soit
plus efficace et qu'ils permettent plus
d'égalité dans les entreprises je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues oui moi je
reviens là-dessus d'abord je voterai
bien sûr ces amendements parce que c'est
important qu'il y ait une meilleure
prise en charge prise en compte des
carrières hachées qui touche nous les
femmes je reviens sur ce que viennent de
dire Madame la président de la
délégation moi je voulais juste que vous
ayez un prisme enfin regardez
l'inégalité entre les femmes et les
hommes et la place des femmes en
ruralité en tant élu rural que je suis
c'est vrai que ce rapport a mis une
lumière sur des stéréotypes de genre
dans beaucoup de domaines et la pointé
l'accroissement des inégalités dans les
territoires ruraux entre les femmes et
les hommes liés justement à la mobilité
et à l'éloignement en particulier des
solutions de garde mais
tout à l'heure monsieur le rapporteur a
dit on va s'en occuper on va mettre une
surcote ça sera l'article 8 j'aimerais
quand même qu'on élargisse le débat
parce qu'on n'est pas seulement des
reproductrices c'est à dire que c'est
pas seulement parce qu'on va faire des
enfants qu'il faut nous récompenser à la
retraite c'est en tant que femme que
l'on a des droits et il faut arriver à
avancer sur notre égalité l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes tout
simplement
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur des
ministres oui moi je voterai
effectivement ces amendements mais parce
qu'il participe aussi d'une volonté de
clarifier de mettre des éléments
véritablement de communication or quand
on parle de retraite aujourd'hui
beaucoup d'usagers beaucoup de personnes
sont parfois en méconnaissance
véritablement de leur situation prenez
l'exemple par exemple des
complémentaires agic à co avec le malus
de 10% pour inciter les gens au-delà des
62 ans à travailler un peu plus mais
vous avez beaucoup de personnes qui ont
le sentiment de prendre leur retraite à
62 ans avec un taux plein que ça soit
sécurité sociale agicaco ils sont pas
forcément au courant de ces moins 10%.
et ces problèmes de communication et
d'information montre bien qu'en matière
de retraite il faut faire beaucoup
d'efforts pour développer des outils qui
nous permettent d'avoir une meilleure
lisibilité de notre parcours
professionnel et donc ces indicateurs
vont dans le bon sens et responsabilise
aussi les entreprises de telle manière à
accompagner le salarié dans son parcours
personnel et dans son parcours
professionnel donc c'est une excellente
proposition et chers collègues vous qui
souhaitez revaloriser le droit au
travail c'est un excellent argument pour
dire bien voilà mettons en lumière les
risques des parcours hachés essayons de
voir de quelle manière on peut
contractualiser avec les branches
professionnelles renforçons le
paritarisme dans ce cas de figure et
deux noms des éléments de clarification
c'est pourquoi cette proposition va
particulièrement dans le bon sens dans
le sens de la communication de
l'information et de la
responsabilisation de l'ensemble des
parties prenantes madame Cohen
merci monsieur le Président je l'ai déjà
dit tout à l'heure cette cette loi que
l'on examine est mauvaise et ça n'est
pas en plus le bon véhicule législatif
et il est bien évident que là on aborde
la question de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes ou plutôt des
inégalités en termes salariale en termes
de déroulement de salaire dans une loi
qui en fait n'est pas destinée à parler
de tous ces sujets puisque il faudrait
une grande loi de travail mais c'est pas
la volonté du gouvernement et on essaye
d'améliorer les choses effectivement
pour nous l'index n'est pas le nec plus
ultra c'est un outil qui peut rendre
visible par exemple les inégalités entre
les femmes et les hommes et les
entreprises contrevenantes n'aiment pas
trop les publicités où elles sont
montrées du doigt ceci dit on peut
toujours détourner un index s'il y a pas
la volonté politique qui est portée par
le gouvernement de faire en sorte
d'encadrer d'augmenter les pénalités de
faire qu'il y ait des critères qui
soient soigneusement établis
effectivement et bien on constate ce qui
se passe au niveau de l'index sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est détourner et ça n'est pas ça ne
permet pas de faire avancer aussi vite
les les choses mais je dis c'est un
outil après là on est en train de
s'attaquer de dénoncer une chose qui est
essentielle c'est que les carrières des
femmes sont hachées parce qu'il y a une
volonté de proposer un temps partiel
subi je rappelle quand même que les
femmes sont à 80% en temps partiel donc
c'est ça qu'il faut remettre en cause de
même que la non que la valorisation des
salaires et que la reconnaissance des
métiers dit féminisés mais à partir de
là bon là la proposition de nos
camarades du groupe écologiste sont aide
nature à améliorer les choses si on en a
la volonté politique c'est pour ça que
nous allons voter cet amendement alors
nous allons passer au scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert pour l'amendement
c'est bon
nombre de votants 344 donc de suffrages
et supprimer 334 pour l'adoption 92
contre
242 le Sedan n'a pas adopté nous passons
au deuxième scrutin public sur
l'abonnement 25 23
présenté par Monsieur Gontard le scrutin
est ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter
autant 344 exprimés 334 pour 92 compte
242 le Sénat n'a pas adopté et nous
allons passer au vote à main levée sur
les amendements suivants présentés
notamment par Madame ponce ceux qui sont
favorables sur l'adoption manifeste en
levant la main
avis contraire
n'est pas adopté ce qu'on peut
considérer sur les suivants que le vote
est identique il est bien
nous allons passer à l'examen d'un
article additionnel après l'article 2
qui sont deux amendements qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion commune madame
Lubin
ou madame Pomerol nous présente
oui monsieur le Président c'est moi qui
vais le présenter nous avons passé la
journée d'hier à parler de l'inex Senior
et monsieur le rapporteur je voudrais
vous dire que nous ne sommes pas opposés
de principes à un index mais encore
faut-il le préciser avec des indicateurs
tangibles qui le composent et avoir
comme l'a dit tout à l'heure ma collègue
Michel meunier un croisement des données
pour qu'il soit intéressant mais surtout
surtout il faut l'accompagner le non
respect de cette index de contrainte
financière sinon nous continuerons à
avoir seulement 36 personnes de 36% des
personnes de plus de 60 ans qui
resteront en emploi et vous l'avez tous
ce qu'on dit et nous en sommes d'accord
10% d'augmentation de l'emploi senior
permettrait d'obtenir 13 milliards de
recettes de plus et qui réglerait donc
ce fameux problème du manque de recettes
de la pour la retraite
comme vous avez refusé hier après-midi
tous nos amendements de suppression de
cet article nous avons présenté hier
plusieurs amendements de modifications
celui-ci en est un autre nous vous
proposons non pas d'exonération de
cotisation puisqu'il n'y en a déjà assez
dans le PLFSS avec actuellement 75
milliards par an nous vous proposons des
gains supplémentaires pour la CNAV par
une majoration du Tour de cotisations
quand on ne respecte pas l'index senior
merci Monsieur Marc
merci Président c'est amendement vise à
inciter à l'embauche et au maintien des
salariés seniors en proposant une
modulation des cotisations vieillesse à
la charge de l'employeur c'est un
modulation interviendra dans des
conditions fixées par des craies en
fonction du niveau des indicateurs de
l'index seniors de l'entreprise
merci la vie de la commission monsieur
le rapporteur
oui merci effectivement là vous proposer
une modulation notamment des pénalités
ça peut se discuter et j'ai le même nous
avons pardon à la Commission le même
raisonnement qui hier à savoir que tout
cela dépend de la négociation avec les
partenaires sociaux donc à chaque jour
suffit sa peine mais soyez attentifs
pour que cette proposition soit prise en
compte au moment de de la loi travail et
nous avons préféré proposer la quelque
chose d'incitatif à travers le CDI
senior et ça répond en même temps à la
préoccupation que nous avons tous par
rapport aux carrières hachées quand vous
avez une carrière hachée qu'on dispose
en fin de carrière d'un nouveau
dispositif qui n'existe pas encore le
CDI senior c'est justement c'est
justement sa spécificité monsieur le
ministre pour être différent d'un CDI
classique que de boire en en compte des
difficultés telles que celles exprimées
tout au long de cette carrière voilà la
spécificité voilà pourquoi c'est adapté
au Seigneur qui ont connu notamment des
difficultés donc avis défavorable dans
la même logique non pas sur la
pertinence de l'argumentaire mais sur
son application plutôt au moment d'une
loi travail
compte tenu des explications que
viennent de nous donner le rapporteur
nous retirons l'amendement retirer
madame pomirol il est maintenu et je le
soumets au vote explication de vote oui
monsieur le compte
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègue je
voudrais défendre l'amendement qui reste
l'amendement de défendue par Madame
pougnol et réagir aussi à ce que vient
de nous dire notre rapporteur puisque il
est préférable
d'éventuellement penser à des
modulations plutôt qu'à créer plutôt
qu'aux dispositif que vous avez fait qui
crée des effets d'aubaine et et risque
au contraire de de provoquer des pertes
de contrat normal pour le contrat
j'allais dire avec des cotisations
abaissées alors que là finalement en
fonction de situation des entreprises et
bien il en sera pris en compte sur les
cotisations vieillesse et c'est beaucoup
plus logique et préférable à un
dispositif qui crée des effets d'aubaine
et qui serait particulièrement néfastes
pour les recettes liées au cotisations
vieillesse merci je soumet au vote ceux
qui sont dans Monsieur le président
rénal oui
madame Ferré
non juste quelques mots pour dire quand
même que quand on finira l'étude de ce
texte qu'est-ce qu'on va finalement voir
et bien que sur énormément pas tous bien
sûr mais énormément demandement
présentés notamment par nos groupes mais
pas que mais pas que la réponse qui
vient c'est si nous avions
une loi travail ou dans le cadre de leur
travail à venir nous pourrons finalement
revoir l'ensemble de ces sujets et même
monsieur le rapporteur vous avez porté
des des avis assez favorables sur
beaucoup d'entre eux en tout cas et donc
je voudrais quand même revenir au fond
parce qu'on a eu également de la part de
notre collègue Annick billon tout à
l'heure la même remarque en disant
finalement si c'était c'est pas le bon
texte pour faire ce type pour voter ce
type d'amendement et donc je ne vote pas
cet amendement parce que ce n'est pas le
bon texte mais après avoir accepté le
fait que ce soit ce texte là que l'on
discute en premier c'est là la faute
originelle si je puis me permettre c'est
que dès le départ dès le départ vous
auriez dû dire ce test n'en veut pas on
n'en veut pas parce que il n'est pas
dans le bon ordre on veut la loi travail
en premier et alors la raison c'est
pourquoi
mais finalement parce que moi moi j'ai
dû rester pour tous et du respect pour
l'intelligence de tous soyez en sûr mais
alors pourquoi vous n'avez pas fait les
choses à l'endroit alors vous êtes
demain demandé par l'État vous auriez pu
dire non et vous ne l'avez pas fait
uniquement
à cause de l'article 7 c'est-à-dire
qu'on cause des 64 ans et bien c'est
navrant
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président revenir donc
sur cet amendement qui au travers de
cette mise à contribution des employeurs
dont le taux de séparation des seniors
dépasserait un certain seuil permettrait
effectivement de financer des droits et
formations pour les seniors les seniors
en difficulté sur le marché de l'emploi
tout en dissuadant les politiques anti
seniors je mets des guillemets au sein
de certaines entreprises voilà pourquoi
cet amendement est proposé parce que on
constate bien que il ne suffit pas de
mettre en place un index et de penser
que les choisiront bien ainsi mais il
faut pouvoir
demander à celles et ceux aux
entreprises qui ne jouent pas le jeu de
contribuer plus fortement je vais
revenir effectivement sur ce qui nous
anime depuis jeudi après-midi de quoi
parle-t-on nous parlons d'une réforme
des retraites même si c'est dans le
cadre d'un véhicule législatif qui ne
convient absolument pas un projet de loi
de finance rectifié de la sécurité
sociale une fois de plus je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure sur l'autre article mais
là également une fois de plus on nous
dit oui mais on aimerait bien faire ça
on aimerait bien faire ci vous avez
raison mais c'est pas possible alors
pourquoi avoir choisi ce véhicule
législatif qui ne convient absolument
pas non seulement ni à la réforme des
retraites mais aussi vous nous annoncez
en même temps une future loi travail mon
collègue l'a évoqué pourquoi renvoyer à
un autre texte que nous ne connaissons
absolument pas pour le moment alors il
faudrait vous faire confiance absolue
sur ce que vous proposez de renvoyer à
cette future loi travail prenez les
choses dans le bon sens et travaillons
ensemble
je me pose et la sablement et je
continuerai à me poser cette question la
pertinence de ce texte nous les
outre-mer
moi j'ai 15 % de 53 69 ans qui ne sont
ni un emploi ni un retrait ni un prix
retraite dans les outre-mer contre 5%
ici en métropole
j'ai une moyenne de 680 euros pension du
régime général contre 901 ici pour les
hommes 715 pour les femmes on a sans
distrimes
en Guadeloupe mais c'est vrai en
Martinique et en Guyane contre 180 ici
en métropole donc des carrières hachées
on parle d'index on parle de choses
adossées à l'index seniors ça s'applique
à 300 d'entreprises aux entreprises de
plus de 300 salariés j'en ai très peu
dans les outre-mer ce texte ne
s'applique pas là-bas ou alors ce sera
une 4C déjà une catastrophe on a ici les
éléments des caisses généraux de
sécurité générale de sécurité sociale et
de l'acnave vous n'en n'avez pas tenu
compte alors moi je je clame et je
demande au compatriote d'être très
vigilant sur ce qui se passe ici et ceux
qui se passera demain après la CMP
merci monsieur le Président juste pour
faire très court le président rénal
faisait appel tout à l'heure pourquoi
nous voulons débattre parce que nous
sommes le Parlement et que nous
souhaitons débattre d'un texte
évidemment je voudrais juste dire par
rapport au références qui étaient faites
tout à l'heure et ben écoutez le 5 avril
dans cette émission le groupe Union
centriste a inscrit une proposition de
loi pour qui vise à renforcer l'accès
des femmes aux responsabilités dans la
fonction publique donc oui nous
travaillons à l'égalité professionnelle
nous travaillons à l'amélioration des
carrières professionnelles pour les
femmes y compris dans la fonction
publique je voudrais juste préciser que
ce texte il est à l'origine c'est un
travail sénatorial de la de ma collègue
comme en Dominique Verrien et Martine
filleul et donc ce sera un texte que
nous allons co-construire ensemble pour
les femmes et les carrières des femmes
je vous remercie madame meunier
merci monsieur le Président pour abonder
les propos de mes collègues rénales et
Ferret notamment
et pour être en accord avec le
rapporteur Savary qui dit que c'est un
véhicule législatif très réduit
je veux même lui dire que c'est un
véhicule législatif pour reprendre les
propos déjà cités qui n'est pas adapté
puisque aucun de nos amendements enfin
aucun des amendements ne sont acceptés
si ce n'est en diminution de prestations
ou sans augmenter les prestations et les
pensions de service parce qu'il sera ils
sont ils recevables et nous en savons
quelque chose ici dans cette partie bon
nombre de nos amendements ont été jugés
comme tel donc c'est un véhicule
législatif qui ne fait que des perdants
et des perdants sur cette ce texte donc
aussi nous voterons un amendement
présenté par notre collègue Monique
Lubin il y a nous allons consulter
ceux qui sont favorables à cette
adoptions de manifestants en levant la
main
avis contraire
abstention il n'est pas adapté
et nous passions à l'examen de
l'amendement de 1599 qui est présenté
par Monsieur grand
merci monsieur le Président
cet amendement d'incitation vise à
prendre en compte l'âge des salariés
dans le calcul des cotisations
patronales vieillesse son objectif visa
renforcer l'employabilité des seniors en
diminuant le coût du travail sans
diminuer la rémunération je vous fais
grâce aux explications techniques
la vie de la Commission
oui je pense que
il y a un effet d'aubaine
caractéristique dans cet amendement là
soyez attentifs je vous demanderai de le
retirer parce que cette décritivité
frais que dès que vous employez
quelqu'un de 50 ans vous bénéficiez de
la dégressivité donc là c'est pas un
coût à 800 millions comme le CDI senior
c'est un coup exorbitant donc je pense
pas que vous soyez dans cette optique là
je pense qu'il y a d'autres dispositifs
qui sont plus intéressantes telles que
la formation professionnelle à
valorisation de l'expérience ou encore
l'aménagement des conditions de travail
donc merci de leur tirer
il est retiré
et nous passons l'examen deux
amendements qui font l'objet du
discussion commune
madame Lubin le présent non madame Ferré
merci monsieur le Président donc cet
amendement vise à proposer d'appliquer
le principe bonus malus à l'emploi des
salariés de plus de 50 ans à
l'initiative des partenaires sociaux
c'est à dire dans le cadre d'un accord
national interco c'est amendement
concrétise une recommandation de nos
collègues dans leur rapport sur l'emploi
dit des seniors nos collègues Monique
lubins et René Paul Savary rappeler que
le dernier accord national
interprofessionnel la ni sur la question
de l'emploi des seniors date du 13
octobre 2005 les partenaires sociaux
s'accordaient sur l'importance de faire
évoluer les représentations
socioculturelles par rapport donc à ce
sujet des personnes je dirais plus âgées
si les objectifs qui étaient identifiés
alors demeure valable un certain nombre
de mesures qu'il prévoyaient sont
aujourd'hui dépourvus d'objets et forcé
de constater également que la volonté
affirmée par les partenaires sociaux en
2005 n'a pas permis d'améliorer
substantiellement les conditions de
retour vers l'emploi des seniors aussi
donc nous proposons de fixer comme
objectif de ce futur Annie de construire
un bonus malus si on l'emploi des plus
de 50 ans
et l'avendement 42 rectifié bis
il est défendu la vie de la
commission
oui merci là aussi ça part du principe
bonus malus
coercition
incitation
index label je pense que c'est une
réflexion qu'il faut mener au niveau des
partenaires sociaux mais soyons
attentifs au niveau des négociations
interprofessionnelles on peut pas
déterminer comme ça un nombre de seniors
c'est sûrement pas le bon niveau c'est
plutôt au niveau des branches où il peut
y avoir des prises en compte de
différents dispositifs et ensuite c'est
au niveau des entreprises qu'il faut
déterminer notamment pour un certain
seuil qu'il faut déterminer une vraie
gestion prévisionnelle de l'emploi des
seniors notamment
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
émettons un avis défavorable ou plutôt
un retrait si vous le souhaitez bien
entendu la ville gouvernement
identique
bien je soumets ceux qui sont favorables
à son adoption le manifeste en levant la
main
il n'est pas adopté nous allons entamer
l'examen de 25 amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune et nous
commençons par l'amendement
ah oui le 42 biches je pense que le vote
est même
qui le présente
madame Lubin
il est défendu
il est défendu alors ensuite nous avons
un amendement 2630 rectifiés bis
il est
madame briquet
merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement du groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicains vis à créer
une surcotisation au bénéfice de
l'assurance vieillesse sur les eaux
salaires pour résorber le déficit
temporaire du système de retraite lié au
papy boom il existe aujourd'hui dans le
droit une contribution des eaux salaires
versées par les employeurs et les
employés pour financer les systèmes de
retraite de l'assurance vieillesse et de
l'assurance veuvage ce dispositif est
intéressant aux yeux du groupe
socialiste car il fait contribuer à la
fois les employés et les employeurs dans
un contexte où la volonté du
gouvernement de réduire toujours
davantage la contribution des
entreprises à notre vivre ensemble de
manière temporaire le papy boom va
entraîner un déséquilibre de ces
assurances qui légitime aux yeux du
gouvernement une contraction des droits
sociaux de nos concitoyens nous ne
partageons pas cette analyse partielle
et partiel et estimons qu'il est
possible de renforcer le niveau des
cotisations pour assurer la solidarité
nationale
il convient de préciser que ce que ce
mécanisme que le mécanisme proposé ne
concerne que les salaires supérieurs à
environ 3650 euros par mois et que le
taux applicable en dessous de ce niveau
est identique à celui existant
aujourd'hui
c'est en cela que nous parlons de
surcotisation sur les eaux salaires au
bénéfice de l'assurance vieillesse
si la politique revient à faire des
choix nous estimons que si ce geste de
solidarité nationale peut permettre
d'éviter la dégradation de la situation
de millions de nos concitoyens alors il
s'agit d'une avancée je vous remercie
merci
l'amendement 4284 rectifiés monsieur
Bocquet alors vous allez avoir une série
d'amendements ce moquer qui déclic des
chiffres ensuite
le 144 de ces 43 vous pourriez peut-être
vous faire une présentation globale
donc c'est un moment entamé une série
d'amendement dans laquelle chacun pourra
trouver son bonheur nous le pensons en
tout cas nous sommes des militants des
jours heureux comme vous le savez nous
l'espérons et c'est un moment vise à
relever le taux de cotisation sociale
déplafonné nous avons fait le calcul
pour appliquer cet amendement au salaire
de l'un de nos collaborateurs au groupe
que nous rémunerons bien au-dessus du
salam médian vous en doutez le salaire
brut de codations salariale sur lequel
s'applique cette cotisation des
plafonnés et pour ce collaborateur 3745
euros on est loin du matraquage fiscal
le formul qu'on entend régulièrement
auquel on voudrait nous faire croire la
part socialisée du salaire de ce
collaborateur et de 148 euros par mois
donc pour une travailleuse ou un
travailleur au salaire médian cet
amendement se situerait autour de 90
euros par mois encore une fois nous
avons des amendements qui suivront à des
taux moins importants monsieur le
ministre
au sujet d'un amendement de ce type vous
infirmiez vous adressant à notre groupe
je vous cite c'est privé les salariés de
pouvoir d'achat avec vous c'est contre
les salariés qu'il y aurait potion amer
et hold-up enfin de citation monsieur
Nice gardons notre calme s'il vous plaît
en augmentant les cotisations nous
augmentons les salaires socialisés en
augmentant ses cotisations des plafonnés
nous faisons peser les forces sur les
plus hauts revenus je sais que vous
n'aimez trop pas trop en augmentant les
cotisations nous augmentons les pensions
de retraite et nous préservons notre
système de retraite en repoussant l'âge
de la retraite comme alternative
vous privez des meilleurs années de
retraite les travailleurs et
travailleurs de ce pays en augmentant
l'âge des parts à la retraite vous créez
une machine à décote une machine à
exclure une machine à pauvreté voilà ce
que je souhaitais vous dire
est-ce que vous considérez que les
abonnements de 32 sont défendus
monsieur gay non
ce Président si vous permettez je
présente ce que vous voulez mais parce
que vous voulez ce que le règlement
permet allez-y merci
c'est le président donc je défends
l'amendement
4283 monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
dans le salaire il y a trois choses il y
a le salaire net il y a le salaire brut
et aussi à la part des cotisations
sociales patronales on l'oublie souvent
c'est tout ça qui constitue le salaire
et donc de à chaque fois qu'il y a des
exonérations de cotisation sociale pas
trop mal versé par le patron en réalité
c'est une baisse de salaire pour les
travailleurs et les travailleurs on
l'oublie souvent et c'est ça qui
pénalise les travailleurs et les
travailleurs non pas en réalité de
vouloir jongler entre le salaire brut et
le salaire net et donc c'est pour ça
qu'à chaque fois nous proposons une
augmentation du salaire brut parce que
c'est tout ça qui participe à augmenter
l'ensemble du salaire et donc dans la
même veine que l'amendement proposé par
mon collègue Bocquet nous proposons
puisqu'il faut parler maintenant de
recettes d'augmenter cette part légère
sur la question du déplafonné pour des
salaires
qui dépassent les 366 euros mensuels et
de porter cet axe un peu au-delà de 4%,
nous pensons que ça participera d'abord
d'un effort de solidarité
intergénérationnelle et nationale et ça
participera aussi en réalité augmentée
le salaire de tout et tous je vous
remercie monsieur le Président
maintenant suivant
ce sera le dernier amendement avant la
suspension merci monsieur
le prix du régime de retraite que nous
mettons en débat vous dites qu'il y a de
lourds problèmes de financement nous
pensons que les ressources existent et
d'ailleurs mes collègues viennent de
vous le prouver le choix vous avez fait
consiste à écarter toute possibilité
distinctes du recul de l'âge de départ
nous contestons cette mesure qui est au
cœur du projet nous formulons plusieurs
propositions orientées dans une autre
direction ce sont deux visions du
partage de la richesse qui s'oppose
notre système de retraite par
répartition repose sur les cotisations
la pension de retraite s'apparente donc
à un salaire socialisé et l'équilibre du
système dépend du partage de la valeur
ajoutée entre capitale et travail or
depuis le début des années 80 la part
des salaires s'est effondrée au profit
de celle du capital dans le partage de
la valeur ajoutée le système de
financement des retraites se retrouvent
impactées en effet chaque point de PIB
qui n'est pas versé en salaire et qui
vaut un manque à gagner de plus d'un
milliard d'euros de cotisations
vieillesse et c'est ce qui se passe
lorsque vous multipliez les exonérations
et les baisses de
du taux de la cotisation des plafonnés
permettrait d'accroître les cotisations
proportionnellement au salaire perçus
alors que les prestations du Régime
général sont plafonnées elle a donc pour
corollaire de faire contribuer
relativement plus les salaires
supérieurs au plafond de la sécurité
sociale et peut permettre de compenser
partiellement les différences
d'espérance de vie entre bas et haut
revenus c'est pourquoi par cette série
d'amendements nous vous proposons
d'augmenter la part des plafonnés de la
cotisation sociale à l'assurance
vieillesse afin de remédier aux déficit
temporaires du système de retraite tout
en privilégiant une solution financière
ne pénalisant ni les passes à l'air en
de ça des revenus mensuels de 366 euros
ni les personnes assujetties tant
l'effort demandé et modeste donc voilà
des propositions que vous allez accepter
j'espère
bien je vais maintenant suspendre la
séance qui sera reprise à 14h30 pour la
suite de l'examen de ce texte la séance
est suspendue